[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ici
patrice roy et nos analystes pour suivre
ensemble ce dernier débat présidentiel
dans cette campagne il faut le dire pas
comme les autres aux états unis est ce
que le trump pourrait réussir à tromper
tous les sondages
est ce que il pourra ce soir se contenir
je pense est une des premières questions
qu'il faut se poser est ce qu'il pourra
laisser parler
joe biden on va vous expliquer dans
quelques minutes qu'on a même changé les
règlements du débat pour permettre que
les déclarations de chaque côté au début
des débats ne soient pas interrompues
donc on va couper les micros
est ce que joe biden de son côté va être
va réussir à comme on dit river le clou
à assurer cette victoire qui est annoncé
en tout cas par les sondages
est ce que monsieur choï encore une
marge de manoeuvre quant à lui est ce
qu'il ya encore un espace qui pourrait
le mener à la victoire et est ce que
monsieur byden dernière question va
pouvoir malgré tout rassurer les
américains et la planète de son énergie
on l'a pas vue depuis une semaine on l'a
pas beaucoup vu depuis cet été il faut
quand même le dire
il a fait campagne là de façon
responsable disent-ils plaide est il
donc beaucoup moins de rallye en fait
pas de rallye compte tenu de la coved
mais depuis une semaine ils se préparent
à ce débat et on l'a à peu près pas vu
tellement qu'on a vu monsieur obama hier
soir légendait bon dieu quelle énergie
on le sait ses talents d'orateur sont
toujours là avec moi et on va passer la
première heure ensemble on se relaye
pour une heure après le débat bien sûr
je voulais représente karine près mon
professeur agréé agrégé pardon à l'école
de politique appliquée université de
sherbrooke
bonsoir rien frédéric gagnon directeur
de l'observatoire sur les états unis de
la chaire raoul dandurand de l'uqam
bonsoir bonsoir il avait avalé
directrice de l'observatoire de
géopolitique de la chair à houdain
du cam bonsoir elisabeth dont cela il
rafa est jacob chercheur associé à
l'observatoire sur les états unis de la
chaire raoul dandurand de l'uqam
bonsoir bonsoir je vous dis tout de
suite qu'on ira voir frédéric arnault
qui est sur place
à nashville au tennessee d'ailleurs
frédéric si vous êtes là j'ai envie
d'aller tout de suite vous voir pour
vous nous expliquer le format de ce
débat à quoi on doit s'attendre parce
que les gens qui étaient avec nous il ya
quoi déjà trois semaines se disent
peut-être est-ce qu'on va ré assister à
une foire d'empoigné une cacophonie
totale
voilà alors justement ce débat mais en
fait il est décomposée en six
thématiques donc c'est quasiment des
blocs d'un quart d'heure les thèmes qui
ont été choisis encore une fois on peut
pas y échapper on parle bien sûr de la
lutte contre la pandémie on va parler
des familles américaines relations
raciales les changements climatiques
aussi qui s'invite dans cette campagne
électorale par le biais de ce débat on
parle aussi de la sécurité nationale et
du leadership alors ce sont des vaste
thème évidemment qu'ils vont déclencher
la passion des deux côtés et justement
pour le politique les passions dans le
fond déborde sur l'un et sur l'autre on
a décidé que lorsque un des candidats
répondent pendant deux minutes et bien
l'autre micro et mis en sourdine
évidemment ça ne plaît pas du tout à
monsieur tron qui préfèrent des échanges
parfois un peu plus vigoureux on veut
éviter ça ce soir est donc c'est cette
formule qu'on a choisi bien sûr une fois
que les deux personnes auront répondu on
ouvrira bien sûr les micros pour qu'il
puisse à ce moment-là interagir et ses
invectives et s'ils veulent le faire
évidemment
parlez moi de la modératrice qui a déjà
été d'ailleurs condamné par monsieur
charmed avance oui exactement
pour monsieur trump en fait kristen
walker qui est une journaliste du réseau
nbc est forcément biaisé il a même
qualifié ce matin de journaliste libéral
ce qui est quasiment une insulte venant
de la bouche d'un républicain comme
monsieur trump c'est une femme de 44 ans
qui a quand même une jolie carrière
derrière elle c'est la plus jeune aussi
des modérateurs qui se sont occupés de
ces fameux débat cette fois ci alors
c'est sûr que ça a été une
et une des cibles préférées de monsieur
tschopp il a déjà dit vous verrez vous
allez voir ce qu'elle va faire ça va
être épouvantable va être forcément
contre moi on peut écouter peut-être un
extrait de monsieur tron justement qui
parlait des fameux micro mis en sourdine
bon ben ça promet frédéric jeu revenir
plus avec vous sur les thèmes bon la
pandémie c'est incontournable
beaucoup déjà disent que s'il perd le 3
novembre ce sera en grande partie compte
tenu de sa gestion de la pandémie et de
sa gestion de sa propre maladie oui
c'est sûr que ça ça lui colle aux
semelles le dossier de lakovic 19
il peut pas vraiment y échapper c'est
sûr que beaucoup d'américains lui
reproche d'avoir aussi une attitude
toujours de ces minimiser les impacts
alors des impacts sont sont énormes pour
l'aller les américains moyens en général
il ya les pertes d'emplois il ya les
difficultés financières les difficultés
économiques puis aussi évidemment il
faut quand même le rappeler il ya plus
de 120 mille morts comme à messieurs aux
états unis on a dépassé le 8 millions de
cas également donc ça dure est-ce que
monsieur trump et on lui a posé la
question cette semaine
est ce que si vous aviez pu changer
quelque chose par rapport à la gestion
de la pandémie
est ce que vous auriez changer quelque
chose il a répondu dans le fond pas
grand chose donc et cette espèce de deux
dogmes quasiment de la part de monsieur
trump de dire et les willis c'est comme
ça et on passe à autre chose et il dit
de toute façon j'ai mieux géré ça que
bien d'autres personnes donc je suis
content avec ce que j'ai fait alors très
bien on verra ce soir ça revient encore
une fois sur la table évidemment patrice
on se reparle merci d'être avec nous
frédéric karen prémontré de rich gannon
il avait avalé raphaël jacob tour de
table qu'est-ce que vous surveillez ce
soir je posais comme ça quatre questions
d'entrée de jeu mais je vous laisse
aller un libre un thème de votre choix
mais qu'est-ce que vous surveillez ce
soir particulièrement karine écoutez
vous avez posé je pense les bonnes
questions au début j'essayais de me
faire une liste justement de ce que
j'étais pour surveiller ce soir mais je
vous avoue que je
j'ose pas trop je sais vraiment pas à
quoi m'attendre ce soir j'essaie de voir
justement en fait peut-être plus
plus fondamentalement est ce que les
deux hommes vont être capables de garder
leur calme ce qu'ils vont être capables
de voir un vrai débat j'en doute je
comprends que les micros vont se fermer
de temps à autre mais bien honnêtement
je suis certaine qu'ils ont encore des
trucs des trucs dans leurs manches pour
essayer de monopoliser l'attention en
particulier peut-être chaume qui se sent
lésé déjà avant même de commencer
alors je pense que je sais c'est le seul
espoir que j'ai c'est un débat civilisé
on verra si mes attentes étaient trop
élevées ou pas à la fin de soirée est ce
que frédéric gagnon elisabeth et raphaël
est ce que il est d'une certaine façon
trop tard pour infléchir d'un côté comme
de l'autre là parce que on le verra dans
quelques minutes
avec philippe gilles fournier
apparemment qu'il ne reste plus beaucoup
d'indécis frédéric ouais c'est très
important il reste onze jours à cette
campagne électorale il ya des millions
et des millions d'électeurs qui ont déjà
voté et on a l'impression que tremper
c'est dans ces derniers ont jour de
mener ce qu'on appelle une baisse
l'action c'est-à-dire de faire sortir la
base un peu la même histoire depuis le
début il essaie de convaincre sa base de
sortir voté le 3 9 en mai vous vous
souvenez à la fin septembre on disait il
et à 42% à 43 pour cent d'appuis au sein
du pays il doit faire passer sa 46 pour
ça ça n'a pas marché pour l'instant et
c'est un peu retour à la case départ
pour lui ce soir comme si on était
encore à la fin septembre mais qu' il
devait atteindre les mêmes objectifs et
la liste des thèmes ce soir est un petit
peu embêtante pour le président
notamment les 15 premières minutes sur
la pandémie
et je constate que rien sur l'économie
là dedans qui pète le thème sur lequel
il est encore plus populaire un maiden
on va parler au deuxième thème quand on
va parler des familles ce sont les
familles américaines il va pouvoir
parler des hausses d'impôts que vous est
proposée monsieur bart hayden et s'il
reste calme
il pourra peut-être faire passer son
message qui pourrait le porter dans
plusieurs banlieues aux états unis que
ces hausses d'impôts par rapport aux
grosses baisses qu'il avait consenti
oui aux très riches mais aussi un peu à
tout le monde y la bête vallée vous
attendez à quoi
moi je surveillerai peut-être le le
flair l'instinct de fauves de trump qui
va chercher à voir où est ce qu'ils
aient le sens et on devrait voir
apparaître à plusieurs reprises mais
peut-être que je peux me tromper
le nom de rangia brydon et on a vu qu'il
cherchait quelque chose qui pourrait
coller aux semelles de joe biden est la
seule chose qui paraît un petit peu
collet c'est cette affaire qui n'en est
pas une salle de routeurs qui lui permet
de dire que cette famille by données
corrompues cas les problématiques et
c'est donc c'est un peu la rouge
m'attendrait qu'il aille chercher ou
qu'il essaye d'abord de faire sortir
bahreïn de ses gonds et que et qu'il
essaye de trouver quelque chose de
déstabilisant qui lui permettrait de
renverser la vapeur parce que vous avez
raison avec la pandémie et le discours
qui prévaut sur la pandémie est ici
aussi dans le débat et pas sur
l'économie les cartes qui vivrait qui
lui sont données ne sont pas
véritablement en sa faveur les faveurs
de trappes tellement jacob qu'on se
demande s'il n'y avait pas eu la
dernière fois ci on ne serait pas en
train de dire aujourd'hui qu'on
s'approche d'une très grosse victoire
démocrate le 3 novembre prochain mais
parce qu on a été échaudés
bien évidemment on est prudent avec
raison mais très prudent avec raison
patrice effectivement il pense que
d'abord et avant tout pourquoi ça tombe
toujours sur du monde je veux pas vous
je veux pas vous le pensez croyez moi il
ya des milliers de personnes qui n'ont
pas votre place de filets 4 isabelle en
examen je pense y voit une très bonne
prédiction en fait une quasi garantie
cas dans leur chambre
vanessa sur la table monsieur dans le
travail de la raison pour laquelle on
peut dire ça c'est qu'on a appris dans
la dernière heure que les invités
d'honneur de monsieur champ pour
débattre ce soir que l'ex partenaire
d'affaires du fils de joe biden entre
eux donc il va assurément amener ça même
si j'ai dit sérieux doute que ce soit
porter à onze jours du scrutin je
gagnais rebondir rapidement sur ce qu'il
faudrait que disait par rapport à la
partie en fait minuscule d'indécis qui
reste frankland ce qui est un des plus
importants sont des républicains depuis
des décennies maintenant
déclaré aujourd'hui que sont selon lui
la campagne de l'élection de notre choix
peut-être la pire qu'ils n'avaient
jamais vu de sa vie et que également
parallèle dans cette tranche donc
minuscule d'indécis les doutes qui
subsistaient n'était pas par rapport à
d'autres choses à faire
il était par rapport à joe biden et si
la campagne de monsieur sont peut-être
plus compétentes ce qu'on essaierait de
faire c'est de soulever des doutes par
rapport au politique précise que veut
mettre la main sur bayonne incluant
justement sur des questions fiscales
comme la hausse des impôts des
entreprises oui il a des arguments dans
la des cartes dans son jeu mais les
joues tout croche et l'élan sur visage
des gens les gens rient même plus
entendre
je vais vous faire entendre messieurs
dames n'ont pas la cacophonie du dernier
débat parce que ça on s'en souvient
encore on n'a rien à apprendre mais des
extraits l'extrême numéro 2 si vous
voulez des extraits de monsieur tron
dans des rassemblements partisans et
vous allez voir on est dans le sarcasme
condé dans la colère mais on n'est pas
dans la vente de son programme
on est content
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que je ne l'imaginais je perds
contre pire candidat de l'histoire ça va
être une honte et il est dans le
sarcasme et des ailes on n'a pas
tellement vu la colère marquée on a vu
plus tôt le côté superman lequel s'est
il a été déclarée guérie élire partie
sur le sentier de la campagne karine
parce qu'il a des cartes à jouer
objectivement mais audrey qui il est
quoi désespérer les notes il ne sait
plus quoi faire
mais je voudrais que tu chantes un set
cette manie de tout centré sur l'humain
le tout ramener à lui même alors la
seule chose qu'il est capable de face et
de transposer sur son adversaire ça veut
dire de faire des attaques personnelles
alors le quelques stratégies que le
calcul politique à ce moment là je crois
certaine que ça lui convient beaucoup et
comme des plus beaucoup de gens autour
de lui pour lui dire des choses qu'il ne
souhaite pas entendre je pense pas
qu'ils aient l'information nécessaire
pour prendre des décisions stratégiques
importantes en temps de campagne il a
été élu en raison de sa personne en
raison de sa flamboyance en raison de
son extravagance
alors évidemment je pense que ce tronçon
sa stratégie si le ciment de ce fier
encore là dessus une deuxième fois et il
semble tout à fait capable de réajuster
réajuster le dit frédéric le mentionner
tantôt depuis septembre qu'on répète la
même chose ils ne parlent toujours pour
même personne parce que sa stratégie est
toujours la même
attaquer personnellement les gens et non
pas s'en prendre aux politiques et vous
avez raison notamment sur le plan des
hausses d'impôts sur la question
justement du système de justice y en a
plein de questions qui pourraient poser
à dubaï d'une qu'il pourrait critiquer
mais il va choisir juste
entre bryant et pas une stratégie à mon
avis très gagnante parce que remettre en
doute l'intégrité de joba edel dans les
sondages actuellement tout ça
non pas que ça fonctionne oui mais
parlons-en d'un travail de recherche
avait dit il n'y a pas beaucoup de
millage affaire il avait êtes vous
d'accord parce que depuis quoi 2 10
jours dans un chai à fox news aux nues
repose on n'arrête pas de dévoiler
certains courriels certains échanges qui
me sont embarrassants pour le fils baden
qui montre qui souligne son alcoolisme
et sa dépendance etc
on essaie de faire un lien bon c'est on
les voit le la page où est ce que est ce
qu'il est ce que ça donne quelque chose
pour le républicain de brazil ça il
avait ça pourrait de la même manière que
les courriels d'hillary clinton ont pu
servir à sa campagne
habilement 2016 et on retrouve un peu
d'ailleurs les mêmes les mêmes logiques
c'est un peu le même plan de match que
celui de 2016
là ce qui paraît être différence c'est
que joe biden a embrassé la question des
moudjahidine ont 10 ans et monfils j'en
suis fier en peinture lui même a reconnu
qu'il avait fait des erreurs en fait
l'histoire est globalement assez
transparente et puis et puis les fameux
courriel que le hockey le new york post
a eu accès c'est d'ailleurs ma
connaissance des sols journaux qui a
publié sa n'ont pas été corroborée par
d'autres sources et il semblerait qu'il
ya des anomalies dans ses courriels là
qui laisse entendre que 17 est censé
être des mails ukrainien mais il ya
certaines certains aspects typographique
qui font que ça ne pourrait ne pas être
le cadeau qui a pas beaucoup de style
autour de l'os en l'occurrence mais
l'idée c'est peut-être simplement de
semer le doute de donner l'impression
que peut-être que cet homme là bas et
demi n'est pas aussi blancs qu'il y
paraît audrey gagnon parce que depuis
quoi j'ai à dire plusieurs années déjà
on connaît cette histoire là du fils
byden qui est allé sur un conseil
d'administration d'une pétrolière qui a
fait beaucoup d'argent effectivement en
se servant de son nom il faut dire quand
même ça c'est ça paraît évident
donc on essaie de faire dire au père
qu'il est en partie responsable de ça et
on laisse même entendu côté certains
républicains que son père aurait même
empoché de l'argent
au détour par ça mais rien n'est prouvé
le seul problème de 3000 peut pas
arriver avec des fers solide là tu
prenais c'est pas avoir un certain effet
dans le sens où ça ça ramène l'attention
sur autre chose que la cause des 19 et
je pense qu'il ya une volonté d'autres
hommes de de reprendre un petit peu le
de reprendre un petit peu le dessus dans
les conversations nationale mais s'il ya
quelque chose dans cette histoire là
quelque chose de concret quelque chose
de fiable il faut que cette information
la sorte au plus vite parce qu'il reste
on jouera la campagne électorale comme
je le disais tantôt et ça reste une
campagne électorale où bien des gens se
demandent s'ils ont envie de trempe pour
quatre autres années au pouvoir donc oui
monsieur bart hayden a peut-être des
choses à se reprocher dans ce dossier là
mais après les électeurs se demande si
c'est pas mieux quand même que ce que
trump a à offrir pour les quatre
prochaines années
donc donc ça ça trotte dans l'esprit des
gens c'est à dire que la corvée 19
devient plus important il ya une autre
chose que je dirait monsieur ben laden a
dit oui mon fils a eu des problèmes de
consommation et je me mets dans les
chaussures de gens à la maison qu'ils
ont aussi des enfants qui ont des
problèmes de consommation et qui voit
monsieur trump casser du sucre sur le
dos de cet enfant qui a eu des problèmes
d'un père de famille qui a essayé de
l'aider
il ya beaucoup de familles américaines
qui sont un peu dans la même situation
et je pas sûr que le message est très
bien reçu par ces personnes non plus
ouais je pense soit que ça marche très
bien alors je vais vous poser je vais
aller voir fait l'objet fourni mais
avant je devais garder en tête la
question que je vous pose est est-ce
qu'il ya encore un chemin de la victoire
pour trame est est ce que ce soit la
question que je posais à haute voix en
début d'émission est ce que je ne peux
river le clou ce soir si une performance
comme correcte est ce qu'il ya comme
river le clou et avec les données qu'on
a c'est pas mal dans le sac pour lui
alors réfléchissez à tout ça frédéric
philippe gilles fournier pardon bonsoir
bonsoir pas très bon commençons par les
sondages nationaux parce que là ils
répètent la même histoire les sondages
nationaux depuis des mois
en effet depuis le mois d'avril si on
regarde tous les sondages nationaux
voici une version mise à jour d'un seul
un graphique que je vous ai déjà
présenté
mais on voit que monsieur 30 n'a jamais
mené dans
intentions de vote depuis avril depuis
que monsieur ben laden est en effet le
nominer des démocrates
et aujourd'hui on a une moyenne de 52 %
pour joe biden 43% pour dans la trompe
une différence de neuf points c'est une
avance que hillary clinton en 2016 n'a
jamais eu même à son sommet et si on
concentre nos reportages voir l anti
fait les bugistes important est ce que
voulait dire c'est que les gens disent
oui mais attention c'est la même chose
qu'en 2016
ce n'est pas la même chose pour les
sondages nationaux qu'en 2016 en est une
son avance est beaucoup plus forte
presque le double qu'avait madame
clinton à cette date si c'est bien ça et
en plus madame clinton au cours de l'été
et de l'automne 2016 avait perdu son
avance et il avait regagné il y avait un
vivier dans les intentions de vote
on regarde ici c'est depuis le milieu de
l'été regardez à quel point les chiffres
et les intentions sont stables ça s'est
resserré en quelque peu après les
congrès démocrates et républicains à la
fin du moins d'août on voit que ça s'est
évaporé ensuite après le premier débat
et on se ramasse aujourd'hui avec encore
une fois neuf points d'avance pour joe
biden
je vous présente un sondage qui est tout
récent de yougov qui est aligné avec les
intentions de vote actuels 52% joe
budden 43% donald trump est ce que vous
avez mentionné un peu plus tôt avec
votre panel seulement 4 % d'indécis et
le sondage yougov demandait aux
répondants est ce que votre choix est
définitif est ce que votre choix et
final 96 % des répondants disent oui mon
choix est fait et seulement 4% des
répondants affirment pouvoir encore
changer d'idée et on rajoute ces hommes
si c'est vrai n'ont cessé si c'est vrai
benjamin jce c'est vrai parce que ça
paraît très très très élevé que 4 %
d'indécis mais c'est vrai les carottes
sont cuites pour trame je vous dirais
que les faits les carottes sont cuites
conscient on considère en plus le vote
par anticipation vous l'avez mentionné
un peu plus tôt en date du 22 octobre à
la même date l'an ii en 2016
il y avait eu six millions de votes par
anticipation et où nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 47,6 millions d'américains
qui ont déjà voté alors que de fait des
semaines que monsieur joe biden mène par
huit neuf dix points dans les intentions
de vote et donc au niveau national ça
serait une
catastrophe pour les sondages si joe
biden devait perdre le vote populaire
maintenant pour les états c'est une
autre histoire bon justement parce que
quoi que l'as vence du vote populaire
une telle avance doit se réfléter
nécessairement dans les états mais par
le calcul des grands électeurs faut
faire attention parce que des états très
populaires comme la californie comme new
york qui vont bien sûr envoyer des
démocrates mais des petits états
républicains vont envoyer aussi des
grands électeurs
donc un grand électeur qui viennent un
petit état a plus de poids que ça dit un
électeur d'un petit étang a plus de
poids qu'un électeur en californie d'où
le jeu alors ce jeu de dans la politique
américaine nous enseigne à être prudents
le calcul que nous faisons présentement
c'est qu'il est possible que joe budden
remporte le vote populaire par cinq ou
six millions de voix et perles quand
même le collège électoral c'est à quel
point le corps électoral et je peux dire
le mont biaisé mais qu'ils penchent vers
les républicains
je vous présente la carte ça c'est la
carte de 2016 et si on regarde la carte
actuelle des projections on voit que
bien sûr il ya beaucoup plus de bleu
dans cette carte si on voit le midwest
qui est un peu bleu foncé et on voit
surtout des états traditionnellement
républicain qui sont beaucoup plus part
que l'habitude on regarde par exemple
ohio le texas l'iowa
on a même caroline du nord et la georgie
ici qui sont de couleur bleu pâle pour
l'instant donc qui sont des étapes pivot
et je voudrais vous montrer quelques
quelques ce sondage ou des moyens de
sondages de certains états importants
particulièrement le midwest et aussi la
floride donc regardons rapidement le
whisky 5 présentement au wisconsin 50%
pour joe biden 44% pour dans notre
propre
on rappelle tom avait gagné par moins de
1% le whisky concert en 2016
on regarde maintenant juste à côté au
michigan ont la moyenne présentement 52%
pour joe biden et 43% pour donald trump
on se dirige encore un peu plus vers la
pennsylvanie les 20 grands électeurs
dont 30 ne peut pas se passer pour
l'emporter
présentement une avance de cinq points
50% pour joe biden et 45% pour donald
trump et finalement j'arrive à l'état de
la floride très important un candidat
républicain pour gagner la floride
depuis 1920 en fait lorsqu'on regarde
l'historique du dernier siècle
d'élection aux états unis mais
présentement en fait ça ne change dans
les quelques dernières heures drogba a
donné 50 % 33 46%
c'est la moyenne 4 points d'avance pour
john dryden c'est considérable oui parce
que si monsieur tron
on l'a beaucoup dit vers la floride le
chemin de la victoire est à peu près
bloqué par ailleurs merci beaucoup
philippe gilles fournier je vais vous
demander en régie de me mettre là les
résultats pendant qu'on va retourner au
panel de 2016 s'il vous plaît parce que
j'ai peut-être suis pas content de mon
explication des grands électeurs ont
envoyée revenir avec mon panel mais à
l'époque l'idée frédéric gagnon était
simple c'était de dire dans le paquet et
les gras le système des grands électeurs
c'était de dire qu' on ne voulait pas
que les villes contrôler la politique
américaine et que donc on avec un calcul
de grands électeurs selon la population
des états on s'assurait que des petits
états allaient avoir un rôle à jouer
dans le jeu politique américain parce
que sinon si on prend l'air si on
prenait une élection directe un électeur
un vote direct mais la californie new
york déciderait à peu près tout le temps
de qui serait le président américain et
alors ça vient de là les grands
électeurs
les pères fondateurs de la nation
américaine suis désolé aurait pas de
mère fondatrice à l'époque mais les
pères fondateurs
elle disait aussi qu'il craignait que la
population fasse les mauvais choix
donc on a créé le collège électoral pour
remettre entre entre les mains de
personnes un peu plus sage est instruite
la responsabilité d'élire le président
la présidente des états unis et ce
système du collège électoral fait en soi
et on le dit tout à l'heure et ça si il
faut le retenir que monsieur trempe peut
quand même gagner l'élection
présidentielle en perdant le vote au
pays en perdant le vote à l'échelle
nationale c'est ça qui s'est passé en
2005 parce que trois états ont fait la
différence on en parle encore cette
année le week en chine le michigan la
pennsylvanie qui avaient voté démocrate
depuis 1992 si ma mémoire est bonne mais
qui ont basculé dans le camp républicain
cette année et la carte convient de
montrer pour deux
weil démontre que byden en reprises déçu
dans ces trois états la et en plus
monsieur trompette en difficulté en
floride en géorgie en caroline du nord
en ohio en iowa
il doit aller chercher ces états là
avant même de facilité actuelle excusez
moi mais ça c'est le oui le l'état à peu
près actuel des choses je ne voyais pas
la floride qui leur est mauve là parce
qu'on ne sait pas avec les sondages puis
avec vous avez l'équivalent des grands
électeurs par et alors là on comprend
mieux ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure et
donc le chemin pour trame est très
étroit dont j'ai parce que mes collègues
en pense mais mais bon je crois que la
floride et à surveiller le 3 en novembre
en plus la floride est un des rares
étapes par adhérent mais à des états au
moins qui n'acceptera pas de compter des
votes au delà du 3 en avant l'arizona
aussi est un état surveillée dans le
sud-ouest et rome doit gagner la floride
et et l'arizona est très important aussi
mais l'arizona râleuse la pennsylvanie
où en plus du michigan c'est là où ça
devient difficile pour monsieur tron
c'est pas ce pas terminé mais c'est
quand même difficile
ok mais tour de table a tué ce que c'est
terminé ou pas pour monsieur trump et
quel est son éventuel chemin de victoire
il la bête à vous j'espère revenir sur
l'histoire des grands électorale ginette
important on critique beaucoup le
collège électoral
mais à l'origine ce collège électoral
avait pour vocation de représenter tous
les états c'était vraiment l'incarnation
du fédéralisme et ça permettait
effectivement si vous étiez dans l'iowa
vous aviez quand même une possibilité
raisonnable de participer à l'élection
du président voilà et puis l'avantagé
des grands électeurs c'est que ça crée
une espèce de loupe sur le suffrage
populaire donc si où on avait une toute
petite fraction de plus que l'adversaire
finalement en bout de course on avait
beaucoup plus de grands électeurs ce qui
donnait une espèce de légitimité
nationale c'était une fiction mais
c'était quand même intéressant sur plan
de la construction d'une nation qui est
intéressant le problème c'est que depuis
le début du 21e siècle on a quand même
eu deux présidents qui sont rentrés à la
maison blanche avec la minorité des
suffrages c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
tout ça aujourd'hui
alors oui effectivement en raison de ce
prisme déformant on peut à vous
par un état ou un autre qui va
littéralement emporté l'élection on l'a
vu en 2000 avec avec la floride ça
pourrait probablement être le cas encore
aujourd'hui on a quand même beaucoup de
d'inconnus dans notre équation
parce que lorsqu'on leur parle du vote
dans tous ses états on présume que
chaque vote compte également parmi les
gens par exemple qui vont avoir voté par
correspondance qui ont voté par
anticipation
on sait déjà que dans ce cadre là le
vote des jeunes parce que c'est la
première fois qu'il voit le vote des
minorités parce qu'il peut y avoir des
problèmes de littératie simplement le
vote de gens qui portent qui ne sont pas
enregistrés ou de ce registre pour la
première fois on sait que ces votes ont
plus de risques d'être invalidée au
moment de la certification simplement
une petite signe différence entre deux
signatures dans certains états peuvent
mener à la validation des bulletins donc
ce sont ça ce sont des éléments dont on
ne sait pas comment est-ce que ça va
jouer le soir de l'élection mais aussi
comment est-ce que ça va jouer par
exemple en cours
ça se fait partie des éléments qu'on ne
connaît pas qu'il autre élément je
trouve important dans les indécis ou
dans l'est le ppe-de indécis les les
gens qui disent qu'ils savent pour qui
ils vont voter ou qui sont très campé
sur leurs positions
il ya aussi tous ces gens qui vont
peut-être voter trump mais qu'ils ne le
disent pas en tant que tel et puis il ya
beaucoup de gens que de nouveaux
républicains qui sont enregistrés sur
les sur les listes électorales etc
donc il ya quand même pas mal
d'inconnues dans notre équation bravo
c'est ce qu'on veut mais juste pour
revenir en arrière aux élèves
je pense que vous parlez de critiques du
système du collège électoral ses 538 en
passant le nom pour les gens qui se
posent la question mais en même temps on
n'a pas trouvé un meilleur système
alors il ay ay ay ay ay il ya deux
fonctions qui vient rééquilibrer la
force relative des régions des gens qui
habitent à la campagne par rapport aux
villes qui est intéressante la taille
d'ailleurs on connaît bien ce système là
on vit c'est pas pareil mais c'est déjà
arrivé ici au québec
quelqu'un gagne le vote populaire et
perdre l'élection compte-tenu des
circonscriptions plus populeuse et tout
cela il ya du vent qui se gaspille entre
guillemets comme le dit votre démocrate
qui se casse pipe
en californie pareil vous voyez mesdames
et messieurs l'arrivée de donald shonda
quel état d'esprit
sera-t-il ce soir je nous posait la
question
un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui parce que
beaucoup de ses conseillers lui dise
raid attac et laisse parler joe biden
qui n'a pas beaucoup parlé s'il parle
beaucoup il pourrait donner des
arguments à des républicains qui ont
maintenant peur de charm de revenir au
bercail alors c'est tout ça qu'on verra
je continue le tour de table
j'étais rendu j'étais rendu à karine
pour le pour le chemin à ce que tu te
rends pas encore un chemin qui pourrait
faire qu'il reste à la maison blanche
mais en fait ce que je voulais aborder
c'est exactement ce qu'ils avaient à 10
à dire qu'on sous-estimé peut-être le
vote porte shop ont levé en 2016
cependant cette année les sondages sont
beaucoup plus fréquents dans les étapes
clés les sondages sont beaucoup plus
rigoureux aussi son se sont
complexifiées un peu un petit peu pour
justement éviter les erreurs de messages
donc on en a plus
ils sont en principe meilleur ce sera
confirmé bien sûr après l'élection donc
peut-être que cette sous-estimation la
lé post si grande qu'en 2016 le chemin
porte chance je pense que c'est le sud
c'est la floride et la georgie en
particulier s'ils tournent vers la
géorgie d'abord symboliquement savent
attendre quand même assez important mais
et de fortes chances qu'ils perdent la
floride aussi à ce moment là donc sa
saveur à toutes fins pratiques fermer la
porte de chambre
la porte de la maison blanche parce que
ça lui prend ça maintenant avec toutes
ces restrictions au droit de vote convoi
dans le sud qui limitent l'accès jeunes
notamment des afro-américains des
populations les plus défavorisées aussi
mais est ce que il y aura un désavantage
démocrates soient aussi on sera
malheureusement seulement la fin de
l'élection
non parce qu'on veut pas tout ça
brouille encore c'est vous encore la
question patrice j'ai comme l'impression
que c'est le jour de la marmotte
il ya oui on se met encore en théorie en
même temps je pense que lorsqu'on a fait
la première émission spéciale pour le
premier débat
trump hayden ya quelques semaines vous
avez sorti une image qui voulait tout
dire c'est à dire que la différence
entre le vote populaire et le collège
électoral oui elle peut exister même
temps ce qu'ont eue en 2016 pour
reconnaître que c'est une aberration une
aberration que eu lieu avec un écart on
va te populaire d'à peine deux points de
pourcentage leur monsieur bart hayden
selon les sondages est presque 10 points
en avance donc l'image que vous aviez
sortie patrie c'est à dire que c'est un
petit peu comme une marie qui monte
s'il me marie monte avec cette ampleur
là amendé je m'excuse on pourra pas
limiter les inondations une seule pièce
on va la voir partout et c'est
exactement ce qu'on voit c'est le monde
partout on avait fait ça avec des
sondages comme cela mais moi j'aime bien
parce que moi depuis le début je pense
qu'il ya un vote discrète je pense que
les gens il ya des gens qui veulent
voter le champion honte de le dire même
sur un clavier parce que c'est plus des
sondages téléphoniques
c'est du panel ou cd mais jeu même s'il
ya des façons de dénicher ou au début ce
qu'ils les vraies intentions de vote moi
je pense qu'il ya encore un vote sommes
tellement discret qu'il est difficile à
mesurer
tu prépares nature rapidement pour
monopoliser mais c'est parce que vous
n'êtes pas seul à penser ça il ya le
seul ou à peu près le seul sondage d'il
ya quatre ans qui avait prévu qui avait
franchi la victoire de son autre chose
exactement de ce canal et du groupe daft
rafale gorki tension des républicains
dans certains états où tout le monde
mais madame clinton gagnante avait
projeté une toit de votre chambre et ce
type là est en entrevue au plus tard que
la semaine dernière et lui disait qu'il
s'attendait exactement la même chose
cette année à cause du phénomène que
vous
quick est un phénomène réel soit dit en
passant qui dépasse très largement les
élections là qu'on appelle le biais de
désirabilité sociale autrement dit vous
voulez pas avoir l'air politiquement
incorrect et encore une fois je le
répète la soeur du cadre politique donc
voulait pas donner des réponses qui sont
vues comme étant socialement non
désirable en sondant est ce que ce type
là ne réside essentiellement sait
écouter les gens mentent à leur médecin
est alors prêt y pensez vous vraiment
qu'ils vont dire toujours la vérité en
son genre qui les appelle au téléphone
et donc selon lui il y aura un quotient
clairement de sous-estimation du vote
d'action parc ancien et c'est là que je
raccroche les gens pour ce soir parce
que même si vous on vient dire selon
philippe j'ai fourni qui a pas beaucoup
de dinde et si encore il reste que si la
dernière chance parce que la prochaine
fois qu'ils vont parler là ça va être un
discours d'acceptation un discours de
défaite le 3 novembre où le 4 novembre
au matin
ou plus tard si ce n'est pas réglé mais
donc c'est la dernière chance pour
monsieur choï d'essayer de sauver les
meubles en tout cas parce que la coved
lui a fait mal malgré tout malgré ce
qu'on vient de dire a fait les lacs au
vide lui a fait mal et ça sera le
premier thème ce soir je vous pose la
question après la pause on va faire une
courte pause on veut retourner à voir
frédéric arnold a ensuite et généreux
g nos électeurs américains sont encore
avec nous
c'est intéressant vous allez voir à tout
[Musique]
bon
des images en direct de l'arrivée de joe
biden à ce débat à nashville au
tennessee dernier débat de cette
campagne présidentielle américaine
dernier mais en fait c'est le deuxième
il y aurait dû en avoir un la semaine
dernière il ya eu deux assemblées
citoyennes à la place d'un côté sur un
réseau et l'autre candidat de l'autre
sur l'autre réseau on a dit à monsieur
bailon a gagné la guerre des cotes
d'écouté
la semaine dernière avec 15 millions de
téléspectateurs mais l'autre mais se
trempe avec 14 points 5 points 6 jan
donc c'était pas mal quand même encore
beaucoup de gens qui s'intéressent à la
politique aux états unis on pourrait
être porté à croire qu'il ya des gens
découragés qui décrochent mais ont su
celle de décrocher c'est comme si on
était un peu river on se demande
jusqu'où tout savoir aller finalement
alors eux vont aller à l'université de
belmont ce soir christine walker qui est
correspondant pour nbc news à la maison
blanche va être la modératrice je vous
rappelle qu'elle pourra ce que nous
avions fait je peux en train de dire on
est plus fin que américaine et donc fait
plus facile à régler ses chances et
choses là ici on avait fait ça la
dernière fois à ottawa pour le débat où
on pouvait
bc les micros si les gens n'écoutait pas
finalement et n'arrêtait pas de parler
un par dessus les autres
donc ça a été quand même relativement
efficace ya un an à ottawa alors bref
mais une fois que les deux candidats
auront commencé à parler là les micros
reste ouvert et là il y aura il y aura
débat quand même ce sera pas comme le
débat avis présidentielle qu'on a
auquel on a assisté la dernière fois où
c'était vraiment beaucoup plus polis etc
il reste cette chambre je transforme
repas en agneau ce soir il va pas se
transformer en candidat qui va écouter
toutes les règles c'est impossible à
moins que envers on serait étonné pour
me dire mais à suivre ses dents je vous
le rappelle 15 minutes nous avons et on
leur a parlé depuis le début des
électeurs américains que l'on suit comme
ça depuis plusieurs semaines je voulais
présente julie lesage vous êtes à
houston au texas des citoyens qui vont
voter bien sûr madame lesage bonsoir
gérard poulain akin au new hampshire
monsieur poulin bonsoir gentilles bonne
john vraie vie les pardons village
désolé je vais la voir la prochaine fois
à tout seul en arizona et on lui a parlé
depuis le début un donne à mon beau yayi
à evanston en illinois
bonsoir à vous quatre je commence avec
vous ou julie lesage ce soir à houston
donc vous êtes originaire je le rappel
du québec vous avez des ménages au texas
il ya 17 ans avec votre conjoint vous
êtes propriétaires d'entreprises n'étiez
pas pro trump en 2016 mais vous comptez
voter pour un jeu entre vous comptiez
voter pour lui la dernière fois qu'on
s'est parlé
il y a trois semaines alors vous vous en
êtes dans cette comme spectatrice comme
électrices comme citoyenne américaine
janet dans cette campagne électorale
ben je sais pas si je vais vous
surprendre mais j'ai prochain les dits
dangereux
je supporte toujours trop
j'ai suivi vraiment ce qui s'est passé
dans les deux dernières semaines c'était
très intéressant est ce qu on a des
éléments tous les jours que des éléments
nouveaux qui nous arrive à tous les
jours est-ce que vous parliez du
phénomène des électeurs qui sont un peu
discret moi je le vis à chaque jour
parce que en étant québécoise les gens
assument que je vote démocrate
donc quand on parle politique et ont
toujours j'ai toujours l'impression de
monter votre jambon des pros ce soir
mais dès que je vais dire que je
supporte juan okello ils vont ils vont
avouer mais bon nous on se porte quand
je vois pas de gens qui sont très
content de voter byden je vois plus des
gens qui vont voter contre en bout pour
trois ans de l'autre côté c'est vraiment
je vois pas de je sais pas je vois pas
des luminosités je vois pas de ces
postes fictifs de voter
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui fait que
vous allez voter trop quelle est la
politique ou les 2/3 politique qui font
que malgré des choses qui pourraient
aussi que vous pourriez trouver
inquiétante la sa gestion la coved vous
plains pas qu'est ce qui fait qu'en bout
de ligne on est mieux avec trois mais en
fait moi la raison avec elle je suis
venue aux états unis s'étaient beaucoup
pour le système de santé pourrait en
parler pendant désarmer le obamacare
pour nous ça nous sommes vraiment pas et
des lots moi c'est ce que je veux que
trois c'est la seule chose que je lui
demande ce soir c'est un vraiment
apporter des éléments de son plan parce
qu'il dit qu'un plein idiot il est écrit
brand mais on ne sait pas on en est
seulement aux idées et on sait très bien
que les bases de lens qui est ce système
sont inexistants n'existe plus donc si
le remplace il doit remplacer par
quelque chose qui va qui peut pas être
discutée avant donc j'attends si c'est
la seule chose que je demande que j'ai
compté ensemble puis à coved sa gestion
de sa maladie touche à vous
le japon ébranlé en tout cas mais en
fait moi personnellement je trouve qu'il
ya bien géré la qu'ovide nous ce qu'on
nous demande on était des états unis
donc c'est à dire que le gouvernement
fédéral généralement dans ses collègues
vont remettre le pouvoir aux est aussi
ce qui s'est passé pour nous la gestion
de la qos vite pour moi ça se fait au
niveau local donc c'est le juge de mon
comté qui vont donner les restrictions
pour le masque et pour tous donc je
crois qu'à ce moment lorsqu'il a fait ce
qu'il devait faire le pouvoir qu'on lui
donne et c'était de couper le trafic
avec la chesnaie plus tard avec le roi
mais ce qu'il a fait pour moi c'est très
bien oui la chine d'ailleurs j'avais
raison de dire parce que c'est vrai
qu'on passe sous silence puis quand il
le dit les gens rient mais c'est vrai
qu'il a fermé avec la chine
et c'est vrai que les gens s'opposer à
ça je me souviens très bien d'un fin de
l'émission spéciale à l'époque est ici
c'est de ça s'est avéré être une bonne
décision selon docteur farouche ils vont
les deux maintenant c'est le plus beau
coup mais ce trump le ridiculiser un
petit mot avant de vous laisser quand tu
hamdi sans arrêt la clé médias les
méchants médias
etes-vous l'adav aussi vous croyez que
les que les network américain et cnn et
le new york times et le washington post
se sont tous contre trame de façon
malhonnête de façon exagérée
j'ai l'impression que la couverture
médiatique et les antis toit en majorité
ouais on le voit on le voit beaucoup il
n'y a presque pas de même mais
maintenant c'est ce même les réseaux
sociaux donc oui je crois vraiment que
ces jeux j'entends rien de bien quand
j'écoute les nouvelles donc possible
d'aller chercher des dés
des réseaux alternatifs mais s'il m'a
c'est quand même le rôle des
journalistes de dire ce n'est pas vrai
ce que vous dites non d absolument je
demande seulement que nos couvertures
juste entre parodie de hunter j'aimerais
ça aussi qu'on puisse en parler même si
c'est pas vrai mais peut-être ccc dans
l'est dans les médias dont il faudrait
qu'on qu'on en parle qu'on voit qu on
investigue peut-être que c'est pas vrai
peut-être que c'est vrai avec je demande
juste une justice donc très bien dans 3
julie lesage merci de nous parler je
rappelle et à houston au texas et vous
allez voter dans la roma - de nous on va
se reparler la soirée électorale à moins
d'une immense surprise mais vous ils
vous holmes a dans son camp merci
beaucoup à ce que vous pensez que vous
gagnez j'ai espoir mais c'est vraiment
chaque jour je ne sais pas j'ai des
jours c'est très positif et jours-ci
négatif
donc je pourrais populaire très bien
merci d'être lente quand je vous parlais
tout de suite après le débat à chaud on
fera un tour de table gérard poulain
akin au new hampshire où cet analyste
informatique pour une émission
financière j'avais toujours été dans le
camp républicain
il faut le dire vous avez voté pour toi
en 2016 et pourtant vous avez déjà vous
avez déjà voté buydens atteint des 47
millions d'américains qui a exercé son
droit de vote pour bayonne cette année
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce
qui a causé votre virage vraiment quand
je pense au président pour moi et c'est
pas un homme honnête c'est pas un homme
qui va me diriger dans une manière de de
comprendre qu' il est là pour tout le
monde il a son base
il parle sans base et sait tous que
c'est important
d autres sont tous des menteurs ils
attaquent tous les autres et pour moi
c'est par une personne que je veux pour
président
il m'en bat là il vous embarrassent et
s'il avait fait une campagne plus sobre
je sais pas si on peut employer ce mot
là quand on parle de monsieur thuram
c'est un peu bizarre mais s'il avait
fait une campagne disons un peu plus
disciplinés en parlant des baisses
d'impôts en misant sur les nominations à
la cour suprême en misant sur des
politiques que les républicains parce
que vous auriez pu quand même où il a
été tellement loin dans la démesure que
vous ça fait un bout de temps vous êtes
parti oui mais au début j'essayais à
l'écouté et pense je pensais que
peut-être il va être différent que
l'homme sur la télé ils veulent qu'elles
quelqu'un qui il va changer yves prendre
son rôle sérieusement et essayer de nous
mettre ensemble mais il a commencé au
début avec sept jours des eaux
leur faute c'est la chine c'est pas sa
faute est vraiment ça c'est pas
quelqu'un que je veux pour le mettre le
président acquis 15 pour disposer de
nous amener tous ensemble pour moi j'ai
voté républicain depuis le week-end ou
aux années 80 et c'est première fois que
j'ai voté démocrate et je suis content
alger pas le même avis que julie je
pense que monsieur byden c'est un homme
honnête
il s'est emparé au monde
il a le respect et je sais que beaucoup
de mes amis sont religieux et ils sont
c'est une seule décision pour les hawks
et seul avortement est pour moi je dis
je vais pas faire des femmes les choses
que moi je suis pas prête à faire
c'était pour interdire à une femme
qu'elle n'a pas le choix c'est quelque
chose pour moi c'est pas américain
très couru c'est la seule raison et j'ai
beaucoup de débats sur facebook avec des
amis et jeudi qu' il y à d'autres choses
il ya d'autres choses que je vois
vraiment comme motivation vous dites
même propre et républicains pour voter
merci beaucoup je dois accéléré parce
que le débat on veut certainement pas
manquer le début du débat mais je vous
parle après chantent ils boudent jeunes
ville et vous êtes à tout seul en
arizona vous êtes professeur de français
à l'inversé de l'arizona est originaire
du texas jette démocrate
vous avez voté pour madame clinton en
2016 évidemment je dis évidemment c'est
moi qu'ils ajoutent mais vous allez
voter pour by donne cette année comment
vous trouvez cette campagne et qu'est ce
que vous allez surveiller ce soir
moi je vous dis déjà pour baden et un
mois j'ai hâte de voir ce qu'il va dire
est ce qui va dire et ben je trouve que
son programme et est très bonne
je pense qu'il qu'il est un bon candidat
et moi j'ai hâte de voir ce qu'il va
faire je veux voir une discussion sur
l'environnement d'environnement et aussi
je veux voir une discussion sur le vote
par courriel aussi parce que sais je
sais que c'est un grand débat avec le
président il peut pas à me le votant par
courriel et tout ça très bien alors je
vous parle tout de suite à chaud après
le débat merci d'être avec nous et
finalement vous la connaissez si vous
êtes avec nous depuis le début parce
qu'on lui parle depuis plusieurs
semaines m donat mbaya yi de evanston
dans l'illinois vous étiez vous êtes
passé par beaucoup de chemin où vous
avez été républicaine déçu puis vous
avez vous lorgnez
les démocrates et vous êtes ami faut le
dire de la famille de jack black et là
vous hésitiez vous étiez revenus la
dernière fois que j'ai parlé at rome
j'en ai tous là je vais toujours voté
pour un bon surtout quand je regarde en
tant que parent noire américaine
oui il mon père vient de là mais ma mère
est noire américaine
une descente dans les esclaves des états
unis donc le problème avec le parti
démocrate est que depuis les années 60
et ne font absolument rend absolument
rien pour nous et pas qu'une utiliser et
font que nous exploiter elle compte
toujours voilà elle veut toujours que
nous nous vantons pour eux mais ils ne
font absolument rien pour les noirs donc
dernièrement il y a comment certains
médias le rappeur ice cube avec d'autres
rappeurs et puis d'autre part très connu
dans le monde de la musique qui ont dit
que comme ils s'appellent sqbb l'a
présenté à dano club in agenda et
uniquement pour les noirs américains
pour que les deux parties puissent voir
dès que nous nous avons besoin en tant
que noirs américains dans sept pays
donc sans les peuples noirs américains
les démocrates verront par terre donc
c'est à cause de nous de tous les enjeux
de pouvoir mais ils font rien pour nous
et donc si vous regardez l'histoire de
joe biden avec bill clinton et à commuer
la peine de mort en prison aujourd'hui
voilà il a dit regretter d'ailleurs il a
dit regretter mais est ce que le temps
file mais est ce que lui dit shawn qu il
en a fait plus que à peu près tous les
présidents américains pour les noix 4
s'il fait pour les noirs
mais c'est que je peux dire est que
quand même et l'a accepté de parler avec
nous les noirs américains
pas juste juste plus les minorités
pas juste les gens de couleur c'est
hélas de parler avec nous les noirs
américains par rapport à nos besoins de
notre communauté notre communauté
si vous regardez bien la plupart des
jeunes hommes noirs dont été mis en
prison étaient des personnes qui y
prenez la drogue au lieu de les envoyer
dans les hôpitaux de réhabiliter
programme de réhabilitation
on l'a mis en prison on à la blague un
grand nombre des années mais vous
regardez le fils de joe boyd au coeur
d'un drogué mais pourquoi on fait pas
arrêté son propre fils démontre que
alors oui mais d'accord mais il faut qu
est née l on commet des actes est inégal
pour nous pour nous arrêter mais vous
restez là d'accord vous dites qu'une
injustice et qu'on arrête plus
facilement les noix vous restez là je
dois aller voir nous mon collègue
frédéric arnould sur place à nashville
parce que le débat va commencer dans
quoi 5 6 minutes 7 minutes alors hier
prêt n'est qu'un petit boucan m je
disais que joe biden était absent était
avait disparu c'est obama qui a plus sa
place hier oui tout un substitut on va
dire patrice barack obama qui est sorti
de de sa retenue légendaire pour venir
appuyer clairement monsieur byden il l'a
fait dans un terrain qui lui était très
favorable quand même la pennsylvanie à
philadelphie
monsieur obama avait raflé vraiment
facilement deux mandats notamment grâce
à la pennsylvanie et c'est un peu
surréaliste parce que hier il
s'adressait non pas une foule mais
plutôt à des voitures avec des dés des
passagers à bord qui écoute et qui
appuyés sur leur klaxon à main 2-2 dans
le fond de donner leur assentiment par
rapport à tout ce qu'il disait et qu'on
aime
obama ou pas il faut reconnaître une
chose c'est qu'il est vraiment une
éloquence et tout un tribun c'est des
qualités qu'on ne retrouve pas forcément
ni chez monsieur trump ni chez monsieur
by donne mais barack obama est sorti
pour appuyer deux jours bayonne et
surtout pour dire à quel point il
faudrait un retour à la décence en
politique américaine il dénonçait
notamment les mentions normal président
qu'est
peut-être le temps d'écouter sinon on ne
va pas avoir le temps d'écouter mais je
vais vous poser une autre question
je veux qu'on revienne sur le sur le
présent sur le maintenant les thèmes du
débat comment ça va fonctionner pour les
gens qui viennent de se joindre à nous
alors je rappelle aux étalages ville
d'abord il ya une modératrice christine
walker qui va animer tout ça il ya de
nouvelles règles et il ya des thèmes
intéressants on va commencer en plein
dedans avec la pandémie là évidemment la
porte des biens encore une fois qui
colle aux semelles de monsieur klein qui
peut pas y échapper
lutte contre la pandémie on va en parler
beaucoup de sa gestion ensuite on va
parler des familles américaines parce
que ça ça rejoint évidemment l'audience
qui va les écouter une dernière fois ce
soir ensemble croisé le fer les
relations également raciales toujours un
débat chaud ici aux etats unis les
changements climatiques donc on va
parler un petit peu de ce que les
candidats pourraient faire s'il était
élu ou réélu président la sécurité
nationale peut être l'occasion de parler
un peu plus généralement de la politique
internationale parce que jusqu'ici ça
n'est vraiment pas un enjeu de la
campagne on ne sait pas ce que pensent
les deux hommes par rapport à ce qu'il
ferait pour les quatre prochaines années
au niveau international et bien sûr la
fameuse question
patrice du leadership quel genre de
leadership vous candidat républicain ou
démocrate
allez-vous imprimé à la maison blanche
dans les quatre prochaines années et
encore une fois on le répète c'est un
débat où les micros seront mis en
sourdine quand chaque candidat sera
amené à répondre aux questions de la
modératrice dont deux minutes sourdine
pour l'adversaire et ensuite ils
pourront débattre croisé le fer là les
deux micros seront allumées très bien
par un convoi la modératrice
journalistes pour le réseau nbc qui
explique et c'est la tradition avant un
débat l'animateur ou l'animatrice vient
expliquer expliquer la folle là les
règles que devront suivre les deux
candidats les thèmes enfin ce que vous
voulez de fer qu'elle est en train de
faire on le voit merci beaucoup à
frédéric on se parle bien sûr après sur
djerba tour de table karine frédéric
elisabeth raphaël sur donc on est à
quatre minutes du début du débat
les thèmes ses incontournables la
pandémie ça va partir quand même assez
fort car il commençait avec vous parce
que là donc il ya deux visions fort
différente et de vision par différentes
je pense que ça va s'affronter toulon
parce que quand tu as des carnutes parle
de sécurité nationale je me demande si
justement la question des ingérences
étrangères va pas être soulevée
notamment par joe biden et ça aussi ça
risque de créer des frictions
lorsqu'on a des messages un peu
particulier qui viennent du directeur de
renseignements aux états unis donc ça
devrait affronter l'as tu les
changements climatiques ou si c'est un
autre enjeu dans lequel les visions
s'affrontent mais comme je disais au
début de l'émission en fait moi ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'on entende les
positions des candidats justement pour
que les électeurs
même s'il en reste peu d'indécis que se
faire une tête sur ce qui distingue
politiquement idéologiquement ces deux
en bleu au delà de la rhétorique au delà
des insultes personnelles
oui frédéric quand que monsieur john
leys monsieur baden expliquer ces shows
jeu expliquait même certaines
contradictions ce qu'il veut faire avec
la cour suprême par exemple pas encore
clair aux yeux de beaucoup de gens
frédéric non il n'ya pas toujours
répondu clairement à la question fait il
n'a pas répondu clairement à la question
l'aï dit ces jours ci que toutes les
options sont sur la table mais reste
assez vague sur cette question là on a
parlé de la fonction sourdine mots j'ai
hâte de voir comment ça va fonctionner
parce que les micros sont
unidirectionnelle nous on entendre pas à
la maison je 30 tentés d'intérieur
monsieur bart hayden mais lui vole
l'entente même si on n'en feront pas la
maison parce que brydon va se laisser
distraire par ce un j'ai hâte de voir
j'espère que le débat sera un peu plus
audible que le dernier on a vu mais je
pense c'est conseiller écouté conseillé
la fête c'est peut-être pas le cas mais
il à belfast
ici c'est un fou de lui même encore ce
soir dès lors c'est terminé il ay
restera une poignée de ses supporteurs
oui tout à fait et l'intérêt reste en
fait les tours étaient restés très
calmes pour un vrai que 30 place de la
classe à bail donne pour qu'ils puissent
se prendre les pieds dans les franges du
tapis et idéalement pour bayonne
et que tron parle beaucoup et lui même
se prennent à son tour et tant d'autres
dans cette trappe qui est dans laquelle
ils tombent aisément ce qui est
intéressant dans tout ce qui a été
évoqué c'est le fait que les agences
gouvernementales l' agence de
renseignement dont parlait karine ou
même la ftq qui vient d'approuver leur
discipline pour la pandémie sont
tellement politisé qu'il n'y a plus de
crédibilité ce président a réussi à
ruiner la crédibilité de l'intégralité
de l'institution puis ça va loin quelque
part le fait qu'obama prennent pour la
première fois la parole un président
contre contre le président en exercice
ça témoigne aussi de l'érosion de la
fonction présidentielle à laquelle tous
contribuer en ce moment on trouve que
c'est inquiétant
oui ça vous avez dit saint raphaël la
dernière fois le simple fait qu'on doive
défendre le processus électoral
américain c'est déjà inquiétant mais en
même temps c'est pas inquiétant qu'obama
se soit senti obligé d'intervenir alors
quand on se serait peut-être attendu
est-ce que ce bail de lui même par gerd
soit on le voit plus là je veux dire en
fait on ne voit plus vous disiez tantôt
qu'on le voyait plus depuis le début de
la semaine même le début de l'été je
serais tenter de vous dire qu'on le voit
plus depuis le mois de mars en même
temps patrice je me permets d une petite
analogie d'art qui est un petit peu
comme les coptes l'époque des davosiens
jersey sous jacques la mer c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on a une avance on joue la
trappe et savez vous quoi ah oui c'est
pas excitant mais c'est efficace c'est
pas pour rien qu'il demeure à peu près
10 points en avance donc pour monsieur
martin une soirée fructueuse c'est quoi
ce soit c'est tout simplement une soirée
où il ne perd pas de poids au sein plus
très bien on va laisser la place à ce
débat mesdames et messieurs se
retrouvent après pour une analyse
complète
je vous donne la bienvenue à ce dernier
débat présidentiel entre donald trump et
l'ancien vice-président beitenou trop
belle le débat est commandité par la
commission sur le débat présidentiel
s'est tenue en vertu les protocoles
conçu par l'as des conseillers en
matière de santé sécurité
le public a promis de rester en fait de
ne pas applaudir mille interrompre sauf
maintenant alors que nous accueillons
sur ici le l'ancien président joe biden
et le président total
et b
j'aimerais vous souhaiter une excellente
soirée à tous les deux ce débat va
porter sur ça six sujets principaux au
début de chaque séance un candidat aura
deux minutes ininterrompue pour répondre
à la première question la commission
ensuite du débat uniquement allumer les
micros quand chaque candidat pourra
répondre et la commission va éteindre
les micros exactement où vous des deux
minutes après cela les deux micros
resteront allumées mais au nom des
électeurs je vous demandais bien
évidemment de parler l'un après l'autre
l'objectif ici c'est de vous entendre et
de permettre au public américain
d'écouter tous les mots que vous allez
formulée ceci dit si vous êtes prêts
commençons nous allons commencer par en
fait la lutte contre la pandémie
président la première question de pour
vous alors le pays se trouve dans une
nouvelle phase plus de quarante mille
personnes sont à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui il est même ici au tennessee
et comme vous d'eux avait partagé le
débat et bien beaucoup de personnes
manquant sont donc soyez spécifiques
comment est ce que vous allez mener le
diriger le pays
face à cette nouvelle phase 2 minutes
alors comme vous le savez 2,2 millions
de personnes était prévu mourir en a
fermé la plus grande économie du monde
pour combattre cette maladie horrible
qui vu de la chine c'est une pandémie
mondiale
donc vous voyez des excuses un peu
partout en europe et ailleurs également
en ce moment si vous avez remarqué le
taux de décès a descendu 85 % le taux de
mortalité excessive est plus faible que
presque tout autre pays et nous nous
battons avec beaucoup de vigueur il ya
eu une éclosion une montée en floride
c'est fini au texas
ça a passé en raisonnant aussi c est
terminé elias et sur des éclosions des
flambées çà et là bientôt ça va te finir
un vaccin qui s'en viennent le vaccin
prêt et ça va être annoncé d'ici
quelques semaines et ça va être livré on
à l'opération aube speed
qui a la responsabilité des forces
armées pour la distribution de vaccins
je puis vous dire d'une expérience
personnelle j'étais à l'hôpital j'ai eu
la coved
je me suis guéri de je me suis remis de
cette maladie ils m'ont donné ce que
donc appel remède j'étais là pas très
longtemps je me suis vraiment remis très
vite sur pieds autrement je ne serais
pas là et là on me dit je suis immunisé
on ne sait pas encore si c'est pour
quatre mois ou pour le reste de ma vie
mais il ya de plus en plus de gens qui
est guéri ce qui s'en remette
nous avons un problème d'envergure
mondiale c'est à l'échelle de la planète
cette pandémie
j'ai été félicités par les gouvernants
de beaucoup de pays
quant à ce qu'on a fait regardez pour ce
qui est des minces mais visière des
blues et tout le respirateur ya des
milliers de respectables ont produit par
mois on les distribue dans le monde
entier et le virus va partir on est en
train d'arriver à la fin et le virus à
partir très bien monsieur l'ancien
vice-président comment est ce que vous
voudriez le pays à se sortir de cette
crise vous avez deux minutes 226 milles
américains qui sont décédés et leur
signale rien d'autre que vous allez
entendre la personne qui est responsable
pour ne pas avoir pris le contrôle
et je ne dis pas que je ne vienne pas de
responsabilité tout le monde est
responsable de ses excès de mortalité
mais cette personne ne devrait pas être
président des états unis il y a des
milliers de morts par jour aujourd'hui
il y a plus de soixante dix mille cas
par jour comparé ce qui se passe en
europe comme le journal numérique
autonome
si nous ne commençons pas d'interet
bateau nous commençons avec un très haut
taux
on s'attend à ce qu'il y ait plus de
200000 américain qui meurent entre
maintenant et la fin de l'année les
conseillers du président ont dit on
aurait pu sauver 100 mille personnes si
on avait conseillé aux gens de porter
des masques et le président n'a toujours
pas de plan de plans compris en six mois
ce que je ferai c'est de s'assurer que
tout le monde soit encouragée à porter
un masque tout le temps de s'investir
dans les tests ultra rapide et que nous
établissions des normes nationales sur
la manière d'ouvrir les entreprises les
écoles afin qu'ils soient sécuritaires
et leur donner les ressources pour être
en mesure de le faire nous sommes dans
une situation en ce moment où le new
england in china qui est un des plus
sérieux sur une publication monde a dit
la première
pour la première fois que la manière
dont la prise d'un réagi à cette crise
était une tragédie est en paix monsieur
moi je vais me prendre les choses en
charge et m'assurer que nous ayons
ressort présidente aimerait suivre
maintenant revenir sur vos commentaires
vous avez parlé de thérapie donc vous
avez aussi promis qu'un vaccin
arriverait sur le marché dans quelques
semaines et d'une garantie par une
garantie mais d'ici la fin d'année
et je crois qu'il ya de très bonnes
chances il ya deux entreprises d'ici
quelques semaines et ce sera une
distributrice vous pouvez nous parler de
l'union de la compagnie johnson &
johnson font très bien et moderne a
également failli the hand travail et
bien d'autres pharmaceutique nous avons
également d'autres qui travaillent en
collaboration avec d'autres pays surtout
en europe
laissez moi de suivre la succion de
nouvelles informations vous avez dit
qu'un vaccin sera disponible dans
quelques semaines ça pourrait prendre en
fait 2021 afin que avant que les
américains puissent justement avoir
accès au vaccin mais pourtant est-ce que
vous être réaliste dans ses projets
lorsque mon l'échéancier sera plus
précis je ne sais pas s'il compte sur
les forces armées comme nous mais nous
avons les généraux qui sont postés
il y a un chef de la logistique il est
prêt à déclencher la pression et nous
aurons 5012 dès que le vaccin est prêt
il est prêt à déclencher la pression
l'esprit donc un bail donne votre
réaction à 40% en fait des hamacs earl
qui accepteraient de prendre le vaccin
contre le coc vide
si ces dates proposées par le
gouvernement quelles mesures preuve
prendriez vous en ce sens je me
surveille qu'il est absolument sa
précieuse absolument transparent et que
les scientifiques puissent examiner qui
passe à travers toutes les étapes du
processus
écoutez c'est le même le même personne
qui vous a dit que cela est terminé en
date pour pâques que ça allait terminer
cet été maintenant nous sommes devant un
univers très sombre il n'a aucun plan
aucune façon d'assurer dès gens qu'ils
auront un vaccin votre réaction
il dit qu'on n'avait pas de plan non
l'hiver ne sera pas du tout sombre on
s'entraide au père il a réouvert ce pays
on ne comprenait pas la maladie au début
quand moi j'ai interdit tout déplacement
de chinois avec toutes les infections et
ensuite l'europe
mais la chine c'est en janvier des mois
après que j'intègre vraiment xénophobe
que j'aurais dû rester dans le statu quo
mais ils étaient des mois en retard sur
moi et en fait c'est lui qui était
responsable de la grippe porcine et
c'est une catastrophe une grille
beaucoup moins grave que la grippe
normale
c'est une catastrophe si c'est lui qui
avait géré la pandémie on l'aurait 700
mhz est mort aujourd'hui et c'était
virus beaucoup moins mortel que la coved
alors celui qui la gérait pour lui quand
vous savez c'était son chef de personnel
chef de cabinet il a dit que c'était
catastrophique c'était horrible on ne
savait pas ce qu'on faisait
elle me tend à l'arrivée nous dit
comment agir et aussi tout ce qu'il a
dit
sur chaque les saisons qu'il fallait
qu'on prenne mais c'est exactement ce
qu'on a fait mais il était en retard
discret dans ce maiden toute réponse ma
réponse et si les homophobes même pas
parce qu'il a bloqué l'accès des chinois
il l'a fait après que 42 pays les fait
avant lui
et en plus il a laissé des gens il ne
pas forcer des gens pour son écoute 44
personnes aller où on le dit non il a
dit qu'il était transparent que le ch
prison de la chine était transparent que
nous devrions le remercier mais mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après ça on a
commencé à parler d'utiliser le la loi
sur la défense américaine pour protéger
nos gens il a rien fait virtuellement
rien et ensuite il sort de l'hôpital et
il nous dit que ne vous inquiétez pas ça
va terminer très bientôt
écoutez il n'y a pas un scientifique
sérieux aux dents longues et bientôt
écoutez je dis qu'on apprend à vivre
avec le virus on n'a pas le choix on
peut pas sans arrêt dans un sous sol
comme lui l'a fait et bien
manifestement il a fait beaucoup
d'argent je ne sais pas trop comment
mais lui il aime il aime ça se cacher
dans un sous sol mais moi quand présent
je ne pouvais pas me permettre cela moi
je n'ai je ne ne peux pas partir pendant
un an et demi pendant que ça disparaisse
non je ne peux pas j'ai réussi et chaque
rencontre que j'ai et toutes les
rencontres il rencontrait beaucoup de
familles des familles goldston les
familles militaires
chaque rencontre et il me fallait il
rencontre et ce serait horrible d'avoir
un aller tout cela je dis savez vous
quoi c'est dangereux
et si vous la traitez moi je l'attrapé
j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai beaucoup
appris le merveilleux médecins m'ont
soigné dans un bel hôpital et là je me
suis rétabli 99 9% des jeunes se
rétablisse 99% des gens se rétablisse
il faut se rétabliront peut pas tout
faire mais le pays il faut ouvrir nos
écoles et on peut pas fermer le pays
sinon vous n'aurez pas
damman la cdc affirme que les jeunes
peuvent aussi attrapé la maladie présent
vice-président by un jour parler de
votre stratégie maintenant est ce que je
te réponds 30 secondes vous avez bien
premièrement il dit que nous apprenons à
vivre avec
ouais les gens apprennent à mourir vous
qui êtes à la maison qui a une chance
une chaise vide à la table vous mettez
votre maison le ligoter votre mairie ou
autre femme
écoutez en meurent de cette maladie
qu'est c'est quand la dernière fois
qu'il a dit que c'était encore dangereux
eh bien il faut dire aux gens que c'est
dangereux et qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
quand c'est dangereux il dit moi je
prends aucune
j'assume toute la responsabilité
ce n'est pas ma faute que cette année
ici c'est la faute de la chine mais
savez vous quoi ce n'est pas la faute de
john ont plu c'est la faute de la chine
ils l ont empêché le virus de se rendre
ailleurs la chine mais ils ne l'ont pas
empêché d'être propagées dans le monde
et plus nous même et l'europe vice
présidente mme aïda le fait non donneurs
pour moi que lorsqu'on a su que ça
venait qu'est ce que le président fait à
ce moment-là et la digue ne vous
inquiétez pas ça va disparaître
ça va disparaître avant parc ne vous
inquiétez pas ça ne s'annonce ça ne peut
pas se répandre quand il fait chaud il a
dit toute une série de choses et même
aujourd'hui il pense que nous sommes en
contrôle de la situation
on va perdre deux cent mille personnes
de plus les nôtres avaient coûté
peut-être pour clore le sujet oui je
plaisantais avec l'eau de javel
mais quand moi j fermer la frontière est
modique cette énergie pendant des mois
et nancy pelosi a dit la même chose
est un trait de danser dans les rues à
san francisco moi j'ai entendu il m'a
appelé un xylophone et même raciste
parce que je fermais la frontière avec
la chine
là il me dit qu il a fallu agir plus tôt
jo ça marche pas comme ça j'ai pas dit
oui c'est ce que tu as dit que j'ai
parlé de la xénophobie dans un contexte
différent c'était pas propos de la
fermeture de la frontière
sa pensée et il a dit il ne fallait pas
fermer ni répondre alors parlons de vos
différentes stratégies pour surmonter la
situation monsieur le vice-président de
suggérer que vous si vous devriez
confiné si le scientifique le beaucoup
conseillé qu'est ce que vous feriez
enfin qu'elle survient pas que
l'économie lettone de chômage la
dépression les violences domestiques
étaient quel est le risque par rapport à
l'exposition ce que je dirais c'est que
je vais faire c'est tuer ce virus ne
treiziste virus pas l'économie de notre
pays c'est son inaptitude qui avait
forcé la fermeture d'entreprise c'est
comme ça que les gens ont perdu leur
couleur leur emploi et vous savez plutôt
que d'avoir été dans une trappe de sable
dans son jeu clip de golf j'ai réduit
permet à nancy pelosi et aux
républicains dans le congrès sur les
mesures à adopter
c'est vrai que nous éliminer par la
possibilité de non non je n'élimine pas
mais ça prend des normes si vous avez un
taux de reproduction dans une communauté
qui est obligée de seuils ou bien à ce
moment-là on dit ralentissez votre
économie faible de la distanciation
sociale nourrit n'ouvrez pas les
restaurants ne voudrais pas les gymnases
jusqu'à ce que vous ayez un meilleur
contrôle serait pandémie mais lorsque
vous ouvrez l'économie donner la
capacité aux gens d'ouvrir de manière
sécuritaire
les écoles ont besoin de beaucoup
d'argent ils ont besoin de moderniser
leurs systèmes de ventilation ils ont
besoin de davantage d'étudiants
et lui il refuse de davantage de buts je
pense qu'il faut réduire et ensuite une
qualité
merci de votre compréhension il ne peint
que du confinement mais oublie le regard
des cours moore dans l'état de new york
regardez en californie la pennsylvanie
la caroline du nord ce sont des
gouverneurs démocrates ils ont tous
fermé ils ont tous confinés et les gens
meurent néanmoins et il les soutient
il ne parle que du confinement non nous
n'allons pas nous confine il faut
rouvrir les écoles par exemple
moi j'ai un fils qui le jeune il a été
déclaré positif quand j'ai parlé au
médecin la 2ème fois ils étaient
déclarés négatifs c'est passé inaperçu
presque je crois que c'est le samu
l'unitaire des choses que vous avez
exigé en fait l'ouverture des écoles et
vous avez assuré qu'on pouvait faire
tout ce qu est un meyer bostons est
devenue la dernière ville justement à
transférer tous aux vertus le contenu
d'une de l'augmentation en fait des cas
que dites vous aux parents qui sont
préoccupés parce qu'ils envoient leurs
enfants
moi je vois dans les écoles le cas le
taux de transmission vers les
professeurs rei très faible mais je veux
rouvrir les écoles il faut ouvrir le
pays
on n'aura pas pays sinon on ne peut pas
agir ainsi on ne peut pas tous fermés a
dit m c'est un pays massif avec une
économie gigantesque les gens perdent
leur emploi les gens se suicident
il ya la dépression de l'alcoolisme la
toxicomanie un niveau du jamais vu il y
a vraiment beaucoup de violence début d'
agression il faut ouvrir le pays j'ai
souvent dit on ne peut pas avoir une
solution qui espèrent que le problème et
lui il veut tous confinés
il va fermer mettre la clé dans la porte
s'il ya une seule personne dans la
bureaucratie qui dit il faut fermer le
pays l'ex-président bayonne c'est tout
simplement pas
nous sommes des gens qui sont capables
de mâcher de la gomme et des marchés en
même temps mais nous voulons réouvrir de
manière sécuritaire et ça prend des
ressources pour se faire par exemple si
vous ouvrez une ré ouvrir une entreprise
vous avez besoin d'avoir de
distanciation sociale dans les
restaurants vous devez avoir les
partitions en plexiglas pour que les
gens ne puissent pas s'infecter et il
faut être capable de faire des tests et
rapide pour s assurer que les gens ne
sont pas infectés il faut faire il faut
retracer les gens qui sont affectés
leurs contacts sociaux est censé par un
conséquent avec le fait de dire que on
veut ré ouvrir mais l'économie mais de
manière sécuritaire
mais tous les enseignants ne vous
inquiétez pas pape sy n'a pas beaucoup
parmi vous qui va me dire ouais je
pourrais dire ceci si on voit ce qui se
passe dans l'état de new york dans la
ville c'est une ville fantôme
quand parler du plexiglas ce sont des
restaurants qui sont en train de mourir
sont à l'agonie ya plus d'argent qui
rentre maître du plexiglas et très cher
et ce n'est pas la réponse
vous avez placé dans un cubicule entouré
de plastique
ce sont des entreprises des commerces
qui meurt vous ne pouvez pas imposer ça
aux gens regardez la baie de new york
regardez ce qui est arrivé à ma
formidable vue pendant combien d'années
j'ai vécu là c'était vraiment très
vivace tout le monde pour abaisser le
nombre de personnes infectées diminuer
le nombre de décès et moi je ne crois
pas à cette vision vous savez d'état
rouge et des tables eux c'est les états
unis dont il s'agit et regarder les
états où il y a des éclosions en ce
moment c'est dans le midwest des états
républicains d etat rouge mais ce sont
tous des américains et ce que nous
devons faire c'est de dire porter
premièrement ces masques s'assurer qu'on
donne de l'aide financière ces
entreprises là ya de l'argent qui a été
approuvé et a rien qui s'est produit ce
n'a pas été distribué new york a perdu
plus de 40 mille personnes
on se présente en clair vous dites une
flambée regardez ce qui se passe en
pennsylvanie où ils ont fermé une porte
regardé ce qui se passait chez votre ami
au michelin où son mari seul quel droit
d'être en affaires c'est risible
maintenant on vient de déclarer que
c'est anticonstitutionnel regarder la
caroline du nord ils ont des flambées et
ils ont été fermés et ils sont en train
de mourir sur le plan financier
jo on ne peut pas permettre cela jo tu
ne peux pas permettre ça il faut rouvrir
l'économie la société
il faut protéger nos et mais il faut
protéger les vulnérables
il faut surtout protéger ceux qui ont
des problèmes cardiaques qui souffre de
diabète
nous avons le meilleur système de
dépistage au monde
justement avant de passer à notre
prochain segment président antoine cette
semaine vous avez dit que le meilleur
docteur vous avez dit qu'il faut aussi
qu'il était un désastre vous avez dit
que comme tous les autres actions
c'étaient des idiots si vous n'écoutez
pas en fait ces gens là qui est ce que
vous écoutez j'écoute tous les experts
je m'entends très bien avec un tel
niveau rocci mais c'est vrai qu'il a dit
ne portait pas de masque
il a dit comme vous le savez très bien
ce ne sera pas un problème
je pense que c'est un démocrate mais ça
va il a dit que ça n'allait pas être un
problème
on n'aurait pas un problème quand joe
dit par exemple que moi j'ai dit car
anthony sanchez essayé d'autres le
d'autres et je ne suis pas en train de
les critiquer on ne connaissait pas
cette maladie on ne connaissait pas
cette pandémie d'où ça venait
quelle était la nature m'a beaucoup
appris mais atelier 10 ne portait pas de
masque et maintenant ils disent il s'est
renversé deux positions et maintenant
c'était ses mots c'est pas un problème
ça va partir des tout donc lui a le
droit de faire des erreurs
bon c'est une bonne personne président
biden votre réponse rapidement et
ensuite on passera la prochaine section
réaction c'est que penser est ce que le
président savait en janvier qui n'a pas
dit ou fait l'américain il lui a dit que
c'était un virus sérieux qui se
répandait par voie aérienne et que
c'était beaucoup beaucoup plus sérieux
que la grippe
il a dit même un de vos collègues qui
l'enregistré ils savaient à quel point
c'était dangereux mais ne voulaient pas
nous dire parce qu'il nous voulaient ils
ne voulaient pas compagnie que les
américains ne panique pas lui il a
paniqué vous savez on a découvert dans
le new york times que ces gens étaient
pour dire aux gens de wall street que
c'était très dangereux et à ce moment là
des courtiers ont dit il faut vendre il
faut vendre
je vous donne et 37 secondes et ensuite
on passe à autre chose quelqu'un était
passé à wall street c'est toi qui prends
tout l'argent doit suivre ses pas mon
cas toi là tu as vraiment a fait
beaucoup d'argent dans les campagnes de
financement
et moi je pourrais en accumulé tellement
plus comme président est quelqu'un qui
connaît la plupart des donateurs
moi je peux appeler tous les dirigeants
des grandes entreprises de wall street
et moi je pourrais fracassé tous les
records mais je veux pas le faire parce
que ça me met en mauvaise posture
et là vous parlez de grosses truites ça
devrait pas être ici car c'est toi qui
prends de l'âge endroit suit pas moi -
ge pourrait écraser son taux de
financement là c'est d'argent on en a
pas besoin
en fait on n'a battu qu'il veut chelsea
n'avait qu'une fraction de son messieurs
2 donc la sécurité nationale jamais
commencer par la sécurité des élections
et certaines nouvelles juste hier soir
et bien des officiels ont confirmé qu'un
nouveau la russie et l'iran travaille
pour avoir une incidence sur les
élections les deux pays ont obtenu des
informations sur les électeurs selon ces
officiels et ils envoient des messages
euros aux électeurs en floride notamment
des menaces donc monsieur vous cite le
vice président que vous feriez vous pour
mettre un terme à sa vous avez deux
minutes il interrogé été très clair et
j'ai demandé à tout le monde de faire la
même promesse de jeu pendant le même
serment peu importe le pays qui
interfèrent dans les élections américain
ce pays va payer un prix c'est très
clair que cours des ces élections je ne
parle pas de la dernière que la russie
est impliquée la chine un certain niveau
et maintenant on apprend aussi que
l'iran est impliqué il peut ils auront
un prix à payer si moi je suis élu il
interfère avec la souveraineté
américaine c'est ça qui se passe en ce
moment ils interfèrent que souveraineté
américaine est au meilleur de ma
connaissance je ne pense pas que le
président en ai parlé à vladimir poutine
je ne pense pas qu'il ait dit un seul
mot à poutine a beaucoup de
l'interférence des rustres et je ne
pense pas qu'il ait parlé aux iraniens
mais peut-être qu'ils en parlent
davantage désireux niais mais aussi la
chose importante mesdames et messieurs
nous avons des pays étrangers qui
essayent d'interférer dans les résultats
de nos et un son propre conseiller à la
sécurité lui ai dit qu'est ce qui se
passe au bout de son ami son ami vous
dit julian et peut-être que je devrais
pas en parler qu'est il est un pion pour
les russes les russes lui donne de
l'information qui n'est pas vrai
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y ait ce passe rien et tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment à propos de la russie
c'est qu'ils veulent s'assurer que je ne
sois pas élu président le prochain
président des états unis parce qu'ils
savent que je les connais et ils me
connaissent
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ce
président n'est pas prêt à faire face à
vladimir poutine alors que poutine et
des primes pour faire tuer les soldats
américains en afghanistan quand ils
tentent de déstabiliser l'otan tout
entier
je ne sais pas pourquoi il le fait mais
peut-être qu'on devrait lui poser la
question pourquoi on off tout pays qui
interfèrent avec les horizons payer un
prix parce qu'ils a fait le succès de
même question laissez moi juste pour
former la question vous aurez deux
minutes pour pendant deux élections en
fait il ya eu une ingérence en fait est
ce qu est ce que vous feriez pour le
prochain mandat pour mettre un terme à
ces réagir la première partie du duo
répondu et à 8 3 millions et demi de la
de la russie jo et c'est par l'entremise
abouti parce qu'il était très proche de
l'ancien maire de moscou et la femme du
maire de moscou où il a reçu trois
millions et demi et votre famille a reçu
cela alors un jour il va falloir
expliquer pourquoi
et cet argent a été versé moi je n'ai
jamais eu d'argent de la russie et pour
ce qui est dit hier soir j'étais au
courant de tout cela et grâce à john
dans le vif qui est fantastique il a dit
ce qui est commun aux deux c'est que les
deux veulent que tu perdes parce qu'il
ya personne qui était plus dur cela
réussit entre les sanctions personnes
qui étaient plus durs à l'égard de la
russie entre les sanctions et tout ce
que j'ai fait avec l'otan - j'ai
provoqué 130 milliards de plus de 130 à
plus de 400 milliards de contributions
au budget de l'otan pendant qu'il lui il
vendait des oreillers et des draps moi
je vends des technologies militaires en
ukraine
ils ont pris le port de soma rêve tu te
rappelles très bien pendant que tu étais
la maison blanche toi et barack obama
ils ont maîtrisé ce qui devrait ce qui
aurait dû être le cren vous vous leur
avez donné mais vous recevez beaucoup
d'argent des russes il vous payez bien
des fonds et il voulait encore
probablement mais avec ce qui est sorti
aujourd'hui s'accroupir avec tous les
courriels et aux courriels auraient même
avec tout l'argent que toi et ta famille
vous remercie et est un vice président
pendant que ça se passe et cela n'aurait
pas juste passé et moi je pense que tu
dois une explication au peuple américain
pourquoi c'est si quelqu'un vient
d'avoir une conférence après c'est pas
longtemps en fait quelqu'un qui devrait
qui devaient travailler pour la famille
bodine mais c'était vraiment dommageable
et indépendamment du moins il faudrait
faire patte blanche au peuple américain
est peut-être un bon moment mais
monsieur le président vous pouvez
ensuite donc la quelle je n'ai pas pris
un seul sou de gouvernements étrangers
de toute ma vie
on vient d'apprendre que ce président à
payer 50 fois plus d'impôts qui le
paient aux états unis qu'il un compte
bancaire secret là bas et ensuite il
fait des affaires avec la chesnaie mois
il dit que je prends de l'âge ans je
n'ai pas pris un seul sainte deux pays
quelconque et en plus moi j'ai donné au
pays
j'ai donné 22 années de mes rapports
d'impôts vous n'avez pas montré une
seule année de vos revenus de vos
rapports d'impôts il y à des pays
étrangers qui vous paye qui vous payent
des gros montants la chaîne également
vos hôtels partout au pays partout dans
le monde et la chine est en train de
construire un nouveau une nouvelle route
un club de golf que vous êtes
propriétaires présents
j'ai appelé mes comptable il ya une
vérification et dès que nous pouvons
déjà l'on rend publics les documents
fiscaux mais beaucoup plus important les
gens parlent de 750 $ comme est pour je
leur ai demandé une semaine
qu'est ce que j'ai payé est ben oui
monsieur il ya eu les prépaiements de
dizaines de millions gbp hier
vance depuis quelques années des
dizaines de millions de dollars en
paiements anticipés
parce que tôt ou tard et disent que
c'est elle estimé qu' il va falloir
peut-être le faire donc ces déversements
accidentels courir ce n'était pas écrit
les épisodes toujours de ses 750 dollars
moi je pense que c'est un des frais tout
simplement de dépôts de dossiers mais
moi j'ai pays des millions de dollars en
impôts première la deuxième en moi je ne
vais pas fait d'argent chez toi oui on
ne crée n'ont plus de toit
oui moi je ne fais pas d'argent avec la
russie toi tu as fait trois millions et
demi jo et ton fils ils ont même
déclaration selon laquelle il faut
donner 10 % au numéro un c'est toi
numéro un an
n'est ce pas il faut donner 10 % le roi
john explique toi c'est terrible non
messieurs je voudrais vous poser
quelques questions mais je veux
permettre de répondre et a brillamment
vous avez dit que vous avez parlé à des
conseillers par rapport aux est ce qu'on
vous a dit quand est ce que vous allez
diffusé en faites vos comptes
vous allez diffuser les documents que je
me suis vraiment traités pire que le tea
portée car ya beaucoup de gens au revenu
national qui me traitent horriblement
tout était réglé jusqu'à ce que j'ai
décidé de me présenter à la présidence
je suis vraiment mal traités par les
autorités fiscales tout était réglé et
dès que s'est terminée la vérification
tout vat rendu public mais j'ai payé des
millions $ et ses pieds que de payer gpi
de façon anticipée d'accord d'accord
maintenant j'aimerais vous poser une
question au sujet à tous les deux de les
questions qui ont été soulevées je vous
donnais la possibilité de parler de ces
questions plus largement donc répondait
très rapidement il se fait quatre ans
qu'il dirait qu'ils racontent la même
chose montrez-nous vous reprenez pour
était de rigoler
arrêtez de manoeuvre et personne ne le
sait zykë votre robe ce qu'on sait c'est
que vous ne payez pas de taxes ou alors
vous payer des taxes ainsi faible prix
la dernière fois qu'il a dit oh j'ai
payé si peu parce que je suis
intelligent je sais comment fonctionne
le système passé à deux autres questions
pour vous de moi j'ai été la victime
d'une chasse aux sorcières pendant trois
ans c'était vraiment incroyable
ils ont espionné lors de ma campagne
aucun président ne devrait subir le
traitement moelleux par exemple et 18
démocrates en colère et les agents du
ahly est partout on passe dépensé 48
millions $
ils ont passé ou films ou opel fait tout
ce qu'ils pouvaient y auriez trouvé
aucune collision 48 millions $
moi si je dépensais a mis lyon sur toi
je trouve rappelé un truc parce que
quand on voit ce que tu as fait ce que
ta famille a pris ton frère afin de
générer des millions $ dont l'autre
frère a fait une fortune et ça c'est
tout grâce à toi et on dit que toi tu as
des commissions occultes est à des
maisons partout tu vis très bien mais
c'est trop c'est comme si cette
consultation à 6 près de baden a eu des
questions au sujet de votre de votre
fils du travail de votre fils en chine
et puis en ukraine aussi alors est ce
qu'il y a des liens qui est des choses
qui étaient inappropriés mimétique
maintenant à propos de l'ukraine
on a eu toute cette question parce que
il était sur le conseil d'administration
de bouddhisme à une entreprise est bien
à cause de ça j'aurais fait quelque
chose de pas correct mais toutes les
personnes qui ont témoigné pendant le
procès qu'on a eue au congrès personne
dit que j'avais fait quelque chose que
j'avais fait quelque chose qui n'était
pas légal la personne qui sait
te retrouver avec des problèmes en
ukraine c'était forcer le gouvernement
ukrainien à dire des choses que je n'ai
jamais fait il les a il les a fait
chanter mon fils
qu'est ce qu'on appelait à propos de la
chine
on a lâché la seule personne qui a fait
de l'argent avec la chine c'est lui et
personne d'autre
posez vous la question est ce que je
peux dire un mot très vraiment son fils
n'avait aucun emploi pendant des années
tristement il n'était plus dans les
militaires j'en dis pas plus n'avaient
pas d'emploi
dès qu'il est devenu vice-président
maurice mann est pas une très bonne
réputation comme entreprise j'entends
dire qu'ils n'ont plus obéissants 83
mille dollars par mois
183 me et même la corse près de trois
millions et demi très rapidement et
ensuite je passais une question il n'y a
pas tellement gavés enquête là-dessus
arrivée à la maison blanche
eh bien vous avez personnellement promu
en fait vos entreprises à l'étranger un
rapport justement indique de cette
semaine indique votre entreprise à un
compte bancaire en chine alors comment
est ce que vous ne jouiez du camaq un
vaudois de conflits d'intérêts la liste
ils sont partout j'étais un homme
d'affaires moi je faisais à faire le
compte en banque dont vous parlez chacun
ans connaît l'existence et lit dans la
liste ce compte là c'était en 2013
voilà il a été ouvert en 2013 et faire
le meilleur 2015 je crois et ensuite
j'ai décidé parce que je pensais avoir
une transaction avec la chine comme des
millions d'autres et j'ai pensé je me
suis dit non j'aime pas trop
7 et 10 le compte a été ouvert il est l
armée laissez moi parler et à la
différence de lui quand il est vice
président est en affaires en même temps
j'ai décidé de me présenter à la
présidence paraissent pas après j'ai
fermé le compte à vin même de me
présenter à la maison blanche
donc une très grande différence lui vice
président des états unis d'amérique et
son fils son frère et son autre frère
sont un train de s'enrichir
ils sont comme un aspect d'accord vous
demandez vice-président base et des
questions au sujet de la chine
parlons-en
plus largement bien évidemment président
tiab a affirmé qu'il devrait payer pour
ne pas avoir fait preuve de transparence
par rapport au corona virus si vous
étiez président est-ce que vous oblige
auriez la chine a payé et à quoi ça
ressemblerait ce que je demanderai à la
chine de faire de jouer selon les règles
du jeu pas comme lui fait lille a forcé
le prix et dont pékin chine
enfin le commerce qu'on fait avec le
chindaï augmenté par à décembre il ça me
prend un partenaire en chine maintenant
des qui détient 51% et donc qui contrôle
nos droits intellectuels moi je
refuserai de faire ça j'étais encore
vice président on a fait des hommes
d'identification dans
la mère de la mer de chine moi j'ai dit
non on va passer à travers les baies 1
avec hainaut b 52 ils doivent jouer
selon les règles du jeu et qu'est ce
qu'il fait lui
eh bien il va serrer la main des espèces
de dictateurs comme le dictateur
nord-coréen est il
ils piquent nos alliés vous avez m'ouvre
présomption 25 % de l'économie du monde
il faut que le reste de nos amis soient
à nos côtés et qu'ils disent eux aussi à
la chine jouer selon les règles du jeu
sinon vous allez payer le prix c'est
comme ça que moi je vais faire et c'est
comme ça qu'on a fait à l'époque lorsque
j'étais dans l'accord de son
vice-président à répondre encore très
rapidement et coûté un milliard et demi
ce n'est pas vrai dix minutes dans le
bureau et ensuite il revient avec force
tout il y à un courrier très clair où il
est question de ta famille qui veut
faire 10 millions par année pour faire
des pressions politiques est ce que vous
voulez faire plus précisément pour faire
que la chine faire en sorte que la
chaîne la chine est en train de payer
des milliards de dollars surveillé de
très loin de suez qui milliards 28
milliards de dollars à nous aux
agriculteurs ça c'est l'argent des
contribuables la chine s'est pas là
contribuent ils ont fait pour payer
ils ont des vélos leur devise ils ont
également rembourser elle se noue
fernique ont reçu cet argent car y ont
été ciblés toi tu ne les a jamais chargé
et 25% sur l'a6 ne donne pas une car il
est en train d'écraser le corps
industrie de les écouter
il ya une raison pour laquelle
il sort tout cette mahmad intellectuelle
il parle c'est pas propos de ma famille
ou de sa famille c'est à propos de votre
famille et votre famille a des
difficultés en ce moment si vous êtes
dans la classe moyenne
vous êtes particulièrement visés eh bien
on peut pas acheter des nouveaux pneus
il faut attendre un mois est ce qu'on va
être capable de payer l'hypothèque est
ce qu'on va être obligé de dire notre
fille qu'elle peut pas retourner à
l'université
vous savez moi j'ai grandi dans une
famille de la classe moyenne et les
familles de la classe moyenne
aujourd'hui sont en difficulté on
voudrait parler de la famille de ce
monsieur le président de sas est une
déclaration politique s'appliquait ne
prend plus la chine et le lot la famille
autour de la table ça c'est vraiment
d'accord je ne suis pas politicien c'est
pourquoi j'ai été élu changeons le sujet
parlons net allons écouter nos jours le
président vous avez rencontré le
président de corée du nord à trois
reprises vous avez parlé échangé des
lettres vous avez dit qu'il n'y avait
pas eu de guerre n'est pas parler de
test mais ceci dit la corée du nord a
lancé en fait son missile
intercontinental et ne cesse de
continuer à développer son arsenal est
ce que vous trouvez que c'est en fait
une trahison de ce que vous juste
seconde parce qu'on doit passer à la
prochaine question j'ai rencontré barack
obama on s'est assis dans la maison
blanche au tout début très belle
conversation ça devrait être quinze
minutes ça a duré plus d'une heure
il a dit le problème principal si la
corée du nord il
il est certain qu'on serait en guerre
avec eux interne pierre et il a une
capacité nucléaire l'isu
on a vu que moi j'ai une très bonne
relation ce type un peu différent mais
il doit penser la même chose de moi
ils ont une très bonne relation il n'y a
pas de guerre etc dessus savez-vous quoi
jusqu'à quelques mois il est entré dans
une certaine région et moi qui n'ont pas
ce qu'il va pas agir contrairement aux
attentes
alors plutôt que d'avoir une guerre car
séoul est à quelques km 25 km une
millions de personnes soit les
transhumances président banana vous
l'accord corée du nord a mené quatre
tests sous obama mais pourquoi est ce
que vous pourriez justement fait en
sorte que c'est que c'est très clair que
la chine doit faire partie de leurs
d'une entente avec la corée du nord et
je lui dis à la chine quand j'ai visité
au nom de l'administration pourquoi
est-ce que je déménage et des forces
pourquoi est ce que vous reprochez vos
forces dynamiques des matchs des
manoeuvres avec parce que la corée du
nord est un problème et on va continuer
à le faire pour les contrôler c'est ce
que les chinois m'ont dit pour s'assurer
qu'on ne peut pas nous faire du mal
alors si vous voulez faire quelque chose
faites votre part lui qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il a légitimé la corée du nord
il a parlé de son bon ami qui est un
vicieux dictateur il dit à quel point on
est mieux non ils ont des meilleurs
missile capable d'atteindre les états
unis représentent vous avez dit que vous
ne rencontrerez pas le président en fait
de corée du sud sous certaines
conditions aux gars des conditions à
condition qu'ils seraient d'accord pour
réduire sa capacité nucléaire
libre de tout
je voulais pas le faire il n'aimait pas
obama
il ne l'aimait pas il n'avait pas
rencontré d'accord ils ont essayé ils
ont tenté le coup je voulais refuser ça
va avec la corée du nord on n'est pas en
guerre on a une bonne relation vous
savez les gens disent avec nous avons
passé beaucoup de questions on avait une
bonne relation avec hitler avant qu'ils
n'aient kingking qu'il ne fasse une
invasion du reste l'europe
les raisons pour lesquelles il voulait
pas rencontrer président obama sait que
le président obama a insisté sur la
dénucléarisation de la corée du nord
qu'on allait imposer des sanctions de
plus en plus sévère c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas nous rencontrer non excusez-moi
mais non américaines présentes femme
puis oui vraiment laissé gâchis la corée
du nord c'est un piège vous passez à une
autruche et vous les deux ou trois
beaucoup de questions ce soir vers une
période très dangereuse dans les trois
premier mois à la maison blanche avant
qu'on d'accord une solution c'était très
tendu et nous ont laissés catastrophe et
obama serait le premier à dire c'était
le problème le plus important est
maintenant aux familles américaines et à
l'économie
l'un des enjeux en fait le plus
important à leurs yeux sur les soins de
santé comme vous le savez tous les deux
aujourd'hui il ya eu un vote est
essentielle au sujet de mg icon
hibarette à la cour suprême
et justement les soins de santé sont une
lutte donc plus de 20 millions
d'américains aucun justement la
couverture grâce à cette mesure est
votre couverture monsieur le vice
président vous vous appuyez ça
si la cour suprême en fait rejette cette
loi il ya 20 millions d'américains qui
vont perdre leurs droits du jour au
lendemain que feriez vous en fait si
justement ces gens-là perdre leur
couverture
j'ai déjà agi mais personne ne pensait
que c'était possible grâce à la
législature j'ai mis fin au mandat
personnel
ça c'est la pire composantes d'obama
coeur le monde individuel où il faut
payer une fortune pour avoir la
possibilité de ne pas payer pour la
mauvaise assurance santé j'ai me fais
cela s'est fini c'est passé maintenant
c'est devant les tribunaux parce
qu'obama qu'elle n'a aucun sens ensuite
j'ai pris une décision
gérer le système du muc vous pouvez un
meilleur force
j'aurais pas pu prendre une autre voie
et tout le monde très mécontents donc
les primes sont descendus voici le
problème
quel que soit votre gestion le système
et vie si ce qu'on veut faire nous c'est
d'y mettre fin on aurait le mandat
individuel qui sera éliminé je ne sais
pas ça va fonctionner si on ne gagne pas
il va falloir le shérif et on aura
obamacare mais ça sera mieux géré mais
ce n'est plus obamacare parce que ça le
mandat individuel c'est très différent
les et conditions préexistantes sont
toujours protégés ce que j'aimerais
faire c'est un système de santé beaucoup
mieux penser nous allons toujours
protéger les gens avec les conditions
préexistantes donc plein très bien
évidemment 4 vont le faire car ils vont
avoir beaucoup de pression et peut-être
ils auront des problèmes parce que nous
allons regagner la chambre des
représentants mais donc il faut toujours
protéger les gens qui ont des conditions
préexistantes et nous avons 180 180
millions de personnes qui ont de très
bonnes polices d'assurances privées
beaucoup plus avec obama que geobra y
dîne veut mettre fin à toutes ces
politiques à toutes les polices ce sont
des gens qui adorent ce régime des gens
de la classe moyenne qui ont connu du
succès ils ont 5 80 millions de polices
d'assurance santé des familles entières
avec le plein de john en fait ce serait
de la socialisation de la médecine vrai
mais plus le choix ils veulent mettre
fait résilier toutes les polices nous
avons fait un travail remarquable en
santé et nous allons même mieux faire
d'accord vice-président bein oui c'est à
vous donc votre plan appelle en fait
justement le renforcement de obamacare
donc quels sont vos plans si en fait la
cour suprême décide que c'est illégal
vous avez deux minutes pour elle bien ce
que je vais faire c'est faire adopter
l'aube à coeur avec une option publique
et cette option va dire si vous n'êtes
pas capables si vous vous qualifiez pour
munich et demi que vous n'avez pas les
moyens dans votre état d'avoir le
medicaid
vous serez automatiquement enroulée ce
qui sera de la concurrence contre les
compagnies d'assurance santé et ceci
permettra une concurrence qui n'existe
pas en ce moment pour permettre à
medicare de négocier avec les compagnies
d'assurance deuxièmement l'idée que je
veux éliminer l'assurance vous savez
c'était mon combat et les 20 autres
candidats durant les primaires et c'est
pour ça qu'ils aient personne sur qui on
de l'assurance privée ne perdraient leur
plan ils ne perdraient pas non plus six
ans robert maker à moins qu'il décède à
romaine ce qu ils veulent quelque chose
de différent
je veux m'assurer aussi que nous ayons
une situation où on va protéger les
conditions préexistantes lui dans son
cas il peut pas le faire on peut pas
faire ça dans les termes
dans l'absolu ça fait longtemps qu'ils
parlent de ça et il n'a pas présenté de
plan concret encore j'imagine qu'on aura
le plan sur les conditions préexistantes
en même temps qu'on aura son plan
d'infrastructure le fait qu'en deux
heures comme il n'en demeure pas moins
que ça a coûté pour très cher au peuple
américain à cause de son administration
dans le cas du coc vide de 19
des dizaines milliers de personnes dès
millions de personnes ont perdu leur
assurance privée parce qu'ils sont sans
emploi et il eut
les gens qui en qui ont eu la coved en
compte son existence qu'à ce qu'ils vont
faire ce qui est lié à ce qu'a affirmé
le président de fram faut il a dit que
vous socialiste auriez le système qu'est
ce que vous répondrez aux gens qui sont
préoccupés justement par rapport aux
options que ça amène le pays en fait un
système géré uniquement par le
gouvernement dit que c'est ridicule
c'est comme dire que vous savez l'idée
que j parce que il y à une option
publique les gens peuvent choisir ses
rangs le clan socialiste
écoutez la différence avec le président
c'est que moi je pense que la santé
c'est un droit et non pas un privilège
ou une option et moi je suis fier de mon
plan
la plupart des syndicats peu près sûr
principaux syndicats sont d'accord avec
moi
et la plupart des gens aussi qui
oeuvrent de manière sérieuse dans le
domaine de la santé sont d'accord avec
moi
ceci va donner l'occasion une
opportunité aux gens d'assurer leurs
enfants comme il y en a et g chez vous
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire s'ils les
tombes malade parce que vous avez perdu
votre votre votre votre assurance santé
parce que vous êtes sans emploi
présidente femmes écoutez votre réponse
est là pendant 47 ans il a rien fait et
là ils étaient vite un vice président et
cela ça ne fait pas 25 ans de cela c'est
à dire trois en trois ans quatre ans au
maximum
ça fait pas longtemps il n'a rien fait
il n'a rien fait il vu la médecine
socialisée ce n'est pas que lui le veut
écouter c'est
madani camara est plus à gauche comme au
lycée dans les salles nous en veulent et
démocrates en veulent
vous allez avoir une médecine socialisée
tout comme avec la fracturation
hydraulique
on va mettre en voix et mettre fin à la
vanille après qu'ait été nommé a été
très chanceux d'être nommé candidat il a
dit oui
la fracturation hydraulique oui c'est le
feu vert et moi je respecte très bien
comment vous gérez notre offre soit tu
te poses la question pendant unis
il dit même chose c'est pas écouté je
réponds ce que les gens méritent d'avoir
des soins de santé une assurance santé
qu'ils peuvent se payer et mon plat leur
permettra d'avoir des prix beaucoup
moins cher et java coûté 750 milliards
de dollars pour ce faire ils vont avoir
des prix moins chers ils vont être
capable de s'acheter des plans
d'assurance maladie beaucoup moins cher
et de ne pas avoir de surprise
lorsqu'ils reçoivent leur facture y
continuer à en parler mais il n'a pas
fait rien pas une sous traitante parce
que je parlais de travail sur la colline
par amanda sin socialiser hélas ils sont
absentés qu'en fait part d'une option
publique
il est question de détruire ma baker et
le détruire la sécurité sociale et tout
le pays va s'effondrer dans les andes
l'essayer dans son état dans le vermont
et son gouverneur est un gouverneur
vraiment d'accord et c'était et pau
c'est vraiment confus il pense qu'il est
en train d'avoir une élection contre
d'autres gens mais c'est contre joe
biden qui se présentent ici
et l'idée que nous sommes dans une
situation où on va détruire medicare en
fait l'acteur de medicare a dit à propos
de donald trump si en fait le président
continue à faire continuer à retenir les
taxes sur la sécurité sociale
en vingt-trois 2023
la sécurité sociale ici va être détruite
ça c'est le gars qui a essayé de couper
medicare l'idée que donnait le propre
est en train de me faire la morale sur
medicare et la sécurité sont six ans a
surpris dans son passé à notre question
grevy la sécurité c'est de regarder son
bilan ça fait des aides accordées de
façon à un autre mais laissez moi mais
ce président mais je dois passer à la
prochaine question ayant dit non sinon
je rends pas résonnent pas de temps sans
cervelle en hausse mais ces banalités
l'accord pas son analyse la branche suis
vraiment l'idée que le marché boursier
explose vous savez moi au début je viens
à scranton les gens ne vivent pas après
que la bourse au cours des trois
dernières années
avant cette crise les milliardaires ici
en fait 700 milliards de dollars de plus
parce que c'est sa seule mesure mais
qu'est ce qui arrive aux gens ordinaires
chambourcy sont forts et il ne vient pas
de ce côté il a vécu la pana nous allons
désormais d'accord nous allons passer à
la prochaine question les gens de ces
mois passés à la prochaine occasion que
ce soir plus de 12 millions de personnes
ont perdu leur travail beaucoup plus de
personnes se retrouvent sous le seuil de
la sécurité des gens enfin plus
particulièrement des hommes des
personnes de couleur
à washington les cent ans cette lutte
par rapport au plan de sauvetage
qu'est ce que vous feriez pour aider les
gens parce que c'est plausible ne veut
pas l'approuver vous l'approuvez la
suprise d'un mais je doit coopérer c'est
pourquoi nous allons reprendre la
chambre des représentants mais ne sait
plus où je ne vois rien prouvé parce
qu'elle veut avoir des victoires
le 3 novembre vous connaissez cette date
nancy pelosi ne veut pas les prouver on
est tout à fait prêt le faire à la
maison blanche
n'oubliez
on a déjà imprimé 3 plein et cela est
inclus le plein des mots cas cette fois
ci elle n'en veut pas c'est trop pour
l'élection parce qu'elles pensent que
cela dit qu'il ne va pas adopter cette
aide parce qu'il n'a pas les votes des
républicains au sénat
pourquoi est ce qu'il ne vous êtes le
responsable en fait du parti
démocratique le chef
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas en
fait encouragé les démocrates à brouilla
me disent on accepte évolué au début de
l'été ils ont adopté des plans d aide
pour aider les américains c'est pas
comme si scène ça n'existe pas lui il
est resté assis sur sa chaise lorsque
moi j'étais un char du plein de dents
2008 j'ai été capable a été chercher de
145 milliards à des communautés locales
pour qu'il puisse équilibrer leurs
budgets des états vous savez il devait
renvoyer des policiers des pompiers afin
d'être capable de continuer à faire
couler le pays et lui il est pas prêt à
appuyer cette loi est mécano la d'y
laisser leur fallait clfr fayette
c'était un renflouement de vie et ses
états mal gérés par des démocrates
c'était une façon de transférer 10
milliards de dollars des contribuables
vers des démocrates et c'était nous
contribuables qui allaient être versés à
des immigrants illégaux nous allions
nous en occuper mais non j'aimerais bien
les aider mais ce que cela fait c'est
que chacun d'un monde entier va vouloir
arriver chez nous c'était une façon de
s'occuper d'eux autres et c'était pas du
tout reliée à la pandémie
en fait c'était un renflouement pour des
villes et des écoles de la gorge at sea
j'évite je suis un fier démocrates mais
je serai un président américain je ne
vois pas d'état rouge ou bleu mesdames
et messieurs chaque état sur six se
retrouvent rompre avec des problèmes ils
vont mettre à pied les premiers
répondants les policiers les pompiers
les écoles et les professeurs vous savez
je t'ai les pères fondateurs est
intelligent janny sampéré déficit de
commerce en fête et de propriétaires
d'entreprises qui ont des difficultés
croyez vous que c'est le bon moment de
leur demander d'augmenter
justement le salaire minimum à 15
dollars oui je pense qu'une des choses
qu'il faudrait faire c'est de sortir les
gens du trou on devrait les aider en ce
moment toutes ces petites entreprises
il y en a des milliers qui font faillite
en ce moment ils ne sont pas capables de
passer au travers cette épreuve
on y pensait les aider avec de l'argent
pour leur permettre de ré ouvrir leur
entreprise de manière sécuritaire pour
les écoles pour réduire la taille des
classes d'installer des meilleurs
systèmes de ventilation les entreprises
et les écoles ont besoin de l'aide du
gouvernement fédéral mais ces gens là
veulent pas les aider ils ne veulent pas
leur donner à une autre question mais il
est trop notre accent pas les pme
mais c'est un médecin etc aider les pme
de faire monter le 5 minimum alabama est
différente de new york new york est
différent du vermont chaque état a ses
particularités
ça devrait être une option récemment au
niveau de l'état il faut déjà mais c'est
clair mais comment allez-vous faire cela
quand vous forcez des salaires plus
élevés et cela a été prouvé
quand vous faites cela les petites
entreprises congédie beaucoup d'entre
vous pensiez justement à augmenter le
salaire
15 oh là vous l'avez dit que vous
pensiez à augmenter le salaire minimum à
15 de la restitution de parcourir visage
et dans une certaine mesure dans un
deuxième mandant dans un deuxième mandat
mais n'a pas univoque yves acte va
acculer tous ces commerces à la faillite
cela devrait être de compétences
laquelle parfois 15 $ c'est pas mal mais
ailleurs dans d'autres états qu'un tel
accord président arrive très rapidement
monsieur bayonne deux emplois et des
gens travaillent à deux emplois il
travaille à 7 15 à 7 dollars de l'heure
vous savez ces premiers répondants qu'on
voit parader sur les rues qui nous ont
permis de survivre des catastrophes
il mérite un salaire minimum de 15 $
n'importe quoi en boîte ça vous met sous
la ligne de pauvreté
si c'est pas vrai que des entreprises
ont failli venir maintenant la question
de l'immigration messieurs et plus
particulièrement des familles dans ce
contact monsieur le président votre
gouvernement a séparé des enfants de
leurs parents à la frontière au moins
4000 enfants
depuis vous adoptez en fait la politique
zéro tolérance mais les parents en fait
n'arrive pas à retrouver les autorités
ne trouve pas les parents de plus 500
enfants que vous l'avez coyotes des
passeurs des trafics 1 du main les
cartels
il s'en servait pour un trade un pays
maintenant nous avons des contrôles
beaucoup plus rigoureux on a 400 mais de
nouveaux murs on laisse entrer les gens
mais ils doivent arriver légalement est
ce que vous allez réunir les enfants
avec leurs familles eux ont construit
des caches
on dit que c'est moi qui est responsable
des cages et là il avait une photo dans
un certain journal c'était une photo de
ses cages horrible
l on dire garder ses cages le présente
homme qui a fait construire
et là on a compris que c'est en 2014 et
c'était lui
vous avez un plan famille oui nous
tentons tout pour les réunir mais
beaucoup de ces enfants arrivent sympa
rincer les cartels qu'il faut rentrer il
ce président biden laissez-nous vous
laissez moi introduire très brièvement
et puis ensuite une impression pour vous
c'est 500 enfants et plus même sont
arrivés ici avec leurs parents on les a
séparés à la frontière pour les
décourager de venir ici
oui on est vraiment dure ici aux états
unis et maintenant c'est pas les coyotes
qui les ont fait passer leurs parents
étaient avec eux ils ont été séparés de
leurs parents par cette administration
et savoir à l'encontre de tout ce que
nous avons mis en temps comme nation
pollica ce fait on la change hélas pas
l'expression ça qu'ils nous n'avons pas
compris c'est que les cageots à l'acquis
de ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui est
arrivé
des parents ont se sont vu arracher
leurs enfants de leurs bras et
maintenant ils ne sont plus capables de
localiser 500 de ses parents et ses
enfants se retrouvent sans parents ils
n'ont nulle part où aller ces criminels
ces criminels laissez moi vous poser une
question
selon monsieur le président il ya des
journées se sont vendus et sont très
bien traités ils sont dans des
installations super mais certains en
fait non pas été une seule question qui
a construit les cages pose lui qui a
construit les scalps hôtel à vous
interroger au sujet de la politique
anti-immigration donc le présent obama
avait fait une promesse à ce sujet il a
aussi présidé sur un nombre en fait
d'énormes de déportation avant de
changer de direction alors pourquoi est
ce que on devrait vous faire confiance
par rapport à ça parce qu on a fait
une erreur ça a pris trop de temps avant
de la corriger lorsque je serai
président et non pas vice président des
états unis et j'ai été très clair à ce
propos 10 600 jours je vais envoyer au
congrès américain une façon de
naturaliser les 10 millions de personnes
et tout séduit ses enfants de dacca
seront certifiés à nouveau pour être
capable de rester ici et ils auront
droit à leur citoyenneté a abandonné lui
tout ce qu'il veut faire c'est de
renvoyer renvoyer ses enfants ils n'ont
jamais connu d'autre pays qui sait vous
savez si vous avez 5 heures vous vous
pas rare vous font traverser le rio
grande et et c'est illégal au nom laisse
moi ici moment je vais pas retourner au
pays
il y en a qui sont des citoyens modèles
y en a vingt mille qui sont des premiers
répondants qui s'occupe des gens pendant
cette crise de l'aco vide
on leur doit une dette monsieur
présidence ils ont il a eu une vie teint
pour faire ce qu'il promet de faire
maintenant et sans lui tout d'avoir on
s'est débarrassé de plaine politique
horrible comme le fait d'arrêter et de
libérer des immigrés légaux vite à
l'esprit saint il a fait zéro rien n'y
at'il a construit des cages pour
comprise en mal d'enfant non c'est faux
car je ne les lis ou savait de quoi il
parle en ce moment là en fait si vous
aviez une famille qui traversait
quittait arrêter ici eh bien on leur
donnait une date pour se présenter
devant le juge dans conduit on lille on
les laisser libres et vous savez quoi il
se présentait le jour de leur
représentation
maintenant quand ces gens se présentent
ils doivent retourner dans le pays pour
demander l'asile
nous quand on est au pouvoir
les gens venaient ici est demandée
rasil plutôt que d'être assis dans la
presse et en passant une chose
d'important cela montre qu'il ne
comprend absolument rien des lois sur
l'immigration
la remise en liberté écoutez c'est une
catastrophe
violeur meurtrier des gens vraiment
maléfique des voyous des malotrus
pourrait rentrer il fallait les libérer
sur notre territoire et moins de 1% des
gens reviennent on devrait envoyer des
patrouilles art pour les récupérer
revenez dans deux ans dans trois ans on
va vous de vous donner une date
d'audience
vous dites qu'ils reviennent mais non jo
ils ne reviennent pas jamais j'aime pas
le dire mais ceux qui ont le côté la
seule crise et de faible réponse et
ensuite on revient à autre chose je
connais la loi et ce peut vous dire que
passons à une autre question toute façon
on en a pas alors maintenant de notre
prochain enjeu les races en américa et
je voudrais parler de la façon dont les
noirs et les personnes à la couleur
brune
vive la race et dans ce pays en partie
on parle du la façon de parler peu
importe la classe le revenu les parents
qui on estime qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
que de préparer leurs enfants à une
possibilité de se retrouver visé ciblés
par la police même pour aucune raison
d'autres que la couleur de leur peau
monsieur le vice-président dans les deux
prochains bus ne voudrais que vous
adressiez directement à ces familles
comprenez vous pourquoi en fait ces
parents ont peur pour les enfants jeux
c'est pourquoi ils ont peur ma fille est
une travailleuse sociale
et elle a écrit beaucoup sur ce sujet il
a fait sa maîtrise à l'universel
pennsylvanie est une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai commencé à travailler de
l'autre côté du delaware
c'est parce que c'était à 85% un frau
américain je dis à ma fille lorsque tu
te fais arrêter par les policiers
la cedh mains sur le volant mais un
parent doit apprendre à leurs enfants ne
met pas ton capuchon lorsque tu traversé
la rue et sur toi que si tu est arrêté
pour une infraction à la circulation
tu réponds oui monsieur non monsieur les
deux mains sur le volant lorsque vous
serez une victime
peu importe que vous fassiez 300 mille
dollars par année ou quelqu'un qui est
sur les l'aide sociale en fait il y à du
racisme institutionnalisé en numérique
c'est ce que ces vérités sont sont
évidentes que tous les hommes et les
femmes sont égales oui c'est vrai mais
on a amélioré la situation tout petit
peu petit peu l'aiguillé se déplacer
vers une plus grande justice sociale
ce président n'ont jamais il faut
s'assurer qu'il y a de meilleur accès à
l'éducation aux soins de santé ni plus
d'occasions de démarrer votre propre
troupe et toutes ces choses c'est inclus
dans un plan très détaillé que je met de
l'avant il faut accumuler la possibilité
d'avoir davantage de risques jours ci la
violence et moi vous rappeler la
question j'aimerais que vous adresser
directement à des familles est ce que
vous comprenez pourquoi ces parts ont
peur pour les enfants comprend et de
nouveau il à 47,1 au gouvernement n'a
rien fait sauf 1,94
quand il a causé tant
deux problèmes à la commune et noir et
les appeler des super prédateur il dit
super prédateur et n'ont plus jamais
s'en sortir 1,94 dans le loi sur la
criminalité personnes a fait plus pour
la communauté noire que tonneau forme et
si vous regardez avec l'exception des
ballerines comme peut-être mais à
l'exception de abraham lincoln personnes
a fait ce que j'ai fait la réforme de la
justice pénale
obama et joe nom ne l'ont pas fait je ne
pense pas même qu'il aussi car il
n'avait aucune chance de le faire
adopter
il aurait peut-être voulu mais moi il a
fallu vraiment que je tort des bras
c'était pas beau à voir
et chacun le sait et inclut des gens
très à gauche qui ont pleuré dans le
bureau ovale deux semaines plus tard ils
l'ont dit il faut les faire ce président
donc la réforme des prisons et team scot
sénateurs incroyable la caroline du sud
il est arrivé avec cette idée incroyable
pour des zones de perspectives d'avenir
un des programmes les plus réussies des
investissements et croyable et qui en a
profité le plus les noirs et les
hispaniques et les collèges
historiquement noir après trois années
au but rouge et les j'ai adoré son
arrivée dans le bureau vallée on dit
après trois ans pourquoi vous revenez
parce que nous n'avons pas de
financement il faut pas revenir chaque
année parce que le présent obama ne
voulait jamais leur offrir du
financement récurrent
moi je les fais 10 un financement
récurrent et plus d'argent que ce qu'ils
ont demandé parce que j'ai dit vous en
avez besoin davantage le seul côté
négatif c'est que je vais peut-être
jamais vous revoir car j'ai une jeune
fille 2006 et en scène entre nous mais
pas parler de votre passé mais votre
réponse
c'est que je n'ai jamais jamais dit ce
qu'ils m'accusent d'avoir dit mais en
fait en 2000 après que cette loi a été
adoptée depuis un certain temps c'est
lui qui a dit le problème avec le
problème c'est qu'il ya pas assez de
personnes en prison et elle est sur mon
site web vous allez avoir sa citation
exacte la date à laquelle il le dit pas
roulé de jeunes maraudeurs qui se
promenait dans nos villes ça c'est lui
qui avec les san jose sharks five qui
était qui n'était pas coupable de rien
mais que lui voulait qu'ils aient ce
qu'on leur donne la peine de mort ok
c'est vrai qu'il a dit qu'il a commué
les sentences de 20 personnes nous
n'avons nous avons commuée plus de 1100
tencin la loi dont il parle en fait il
n'y a été initiée par un barack obama et
deuxièmement on est dans une situation
ici où le système de prisons fédérales a
été réduit de 38 mille personnes sous
notre administration
une des choses qu'on devrait faire c'est
qu'il doit il ne devrait jamais y avoir
deux sentences minimales obligatoires
dans la loi c'est pour ça qu'on demande
aux états d'éliminer ces sentences
minimales et aussi d'avoir des tribunaux
spéciale pour les usagers de drogues
personne ne devrait aller en prison pour
usage de drogues quoi il ne l'a pas fait
pourquoi ne l'a pas fait pendant tombant
d'un connard 88,1 comme vice président
suppan tout ce que tu vas faire et
patati patata mais tu étais là ya pas
longtemps et vous n'avez rien fait joe
économie moi je me suis présenté
parce que obama avec les pouvoirs parce
que vous avez tellement mal travaillé
sinon je me serais jamais présenté je me
suis présenté la présidence parce que
vous avez si mal travaillé là je te
regarde et paul x et je me suis par
exemple
je vais vous dire une chose j'espère
qu'ils veulent vous savez qui moi je
suis vous savez qui lui l'est vous
connaissez sa personnalité est la mienne
vous savez que j'ai une réputation que
je suis une personne aura mais de dire
la vérité je veux que ça se passe je
suis ici le caractère du pays tout
entier qui est en jeu ici répondre très
rapidement la russie l'ukraine la chine
tout ça c'est vrai direct si c'est vrai
alors c'est un produit axis est
corrompue alors ne dites pas à quel
point tu es un innocent
diot en tain de toi comme paul seco
l'enjeu en fait l'addition
je voudrais rester justement sur cet
enjeu des rats il faut que je réponde
très rapidement il y a trente anciens
officiers du renseignement qui disent
que ce qu'il n'accuse est en fait
quelque chose qui a été inventé par la
russie il y a cinq anciens dirigeants de
la cia qui dit que qu'est ce qu'il
raconte c'est des foutaises personne n'y
croit il y à son bon ami déduis rien et
les ordinateurs macbook retrouver
exactement ce que c'est voilà où ils
savent ah non non non c'est sur la
question non mais franchement la lotte
pousse donc nous allons poursuivre sur
cet enjeu monsieur le président vous
avez décrit en fait le mouvement les
lévy noir compte vous avez partagé en
fait les gens qui parlent qui dénonce
les blancs vous avez parlé en fait de
rois au premier amendement qu'est ce que
vous dites aux américains qui affirment
que ce type de langage de la part d'un
président contribue justement un climat
de haine raciale ou comprendre moi quand
j'ai entendu parler de black ice man
with est un train de chanter de cochon
en part l'un des policiers
il faut leaf rire comme de be king c'est
des cochons et c'était une manifestation
dans la rue et moi c'était ma première
expérience avec brad wildeman ma
relation avec tous les gens je pense que
j'ai de très bonnes relations avec tout
grâce
je suis leur la personne à qui sont
préoccupés justement par cette
rhétorique
c'est l'information aux tirs j'ai la
réforme de la justice pénale réforme des
prisons je me suis occupé des collèges
et les universités noires
je ne sais pas quoi dire ils peuvent
dire ce qu'ils veulent mais les faits
parlent moi ça m'attriste parce que je
suis la personne la moins raciste je ne
vois même pas le public parce que c'est
tellement sombre mais je me fiche bd ce
qui se trouve dans le public je suis
l'appartement est raciste dallas à
l'ex-président baydan laissez-moi vous
demander très brièvement et ensuite une
question de survie pour vous j'aimerais
rink est sans doute le point le plus
raciste
ils versent de l'essence sur chaque feu
qui éclatent au pays il a commencé sa
campagne électorale en disant qu'il est
se débarrasser des violeurs mexicain il
a banni les musulmans parce qu'il était
musulman il
rendu les choses il a fait empirer
toutes les choses et il a dit la
dernière fois pour des racistes blancs
stand-by président de femmes je vous
donnais 10 secondes pour répondre
ensuite une autre question tu vis tu as
parlé d' abraham est comme ça vient d'où
sa douce que ses sorties
non non non y at il eu quelqu'un qui a
fait autant pour les noirs j'ai pas dit
que j'étais à bram et que je dis pas
depuis
mais selon qu'on y at il eu un président
qui a autant agit pour les noix toi t'as
rien fait hormis la loi sur l est qu il
ya eu comme conséquence des dizaines de
milliers de noirs dolois
laissez moi il serait question passe
avec ce président c'est un très mauvais
esprits d'embedone laissez moi vous
donner la possibilité de répondre dans
ce contexte donc un projet de loi que
vous avez supporté vous avez appuyé dans
les années 80-90 vont contribuer à
l'incarcération de dizaines de milliers
de jeunes
noah qui avait de la drogue donc ce sont
des pères des enfants d oncle dont les
familles à ce jour sous faute encore les
conséquences de ces politiques alors
adressez vous à ces familles pourquoi
voudrait-il vos des ponts et chaussées
que dans les années 80 on a tous les 100
sénateurs au sénat ont voté un pow pow
d'une loin sur la drogue et comment
gérer la drogue ici le problème de
drogue
et surtout cette section sur la cocaïne
et c'est pour ça que maintenant je dis
qu'on ne devrait pas envoyé personne en
prison pour une infraction à la loi sur
les drogues
on devrait les envoyer en réhabilitation
c'est pour ça qu'on devrait créer des
tribunaux spécifiquement pour les
infractions reliées à la drogue et les
républicains refusaient de les financer
ces gens devraient aller en traitement
se faire prêter parce que c'est un
problème médical
les genres les américains ont vu que
c'était une erreur de passer ses lois ne
s'était pas vraiment des belles paroles
c'est un vrai politicien que je veux
faire quand je vais te président en tête
et vice président avec obama comme
président au leader pendant huit ans
pourquoi t'as pas réussi un coup à 8,1
rien est là tu dis que tu vas réussir
parce que c'est vraiment rien des
paroles voit ici en faire un bon bout
35000 des prisons fédérales
il y avait des milliers de personnes qui
ont reçu un pardon présidentiel est en
fait c'est nous qui avons mis dans la
loi qu'il faut regarder à ce que les
policiers font comment ils se conduisent
je pourrais continuer mon heure entamé
le processus
on a perdu une élection et c'est pour ça
que maintenant je me présente pour
devenir président pour chaque question
pourquoi n'as tu pas fait ça un 8-1 ça
fait pas longtemps pourtant pourquoi tu
l'as pas fait je vais faire ceci je vais
faire cela
oui mais des milliers de jeunes hommes
noirs ou emprisonnés comme conséquence
de thé proposition de ta loi pourquoi tu
l'a pas fait pendant huit ans parce que
tu n'es que des menaces que c'est jo
parce que c'était un congrès républicain
ça c'est la réponse mais il faut les
confrères il faut les persuader c'est ça
non nous allons passer à la prochaine
saison pour chanel le changement
climatique la justice pénale
il a fallu que je manque de temps alors
doit passer à la question du changement
climatique s'il vous plaît tous les deux
vous avez des visions opposées sur les
changements climatiques présentoirs vous
avez affirmé que la réglementation
environnementale en fait diminue les
emplois vous dise président un bail
donne vous trouvez que c'est une
possibilité de créer de nouveaux emplois
pour chacun d'entre vous combien s
comment est-ce que vous appuyer la
croissance de l'emploi
je commence par vous ou président trempe
alors écoutez on a le programme de
billons d'arbres temps de programmes
j'adore l'environnement ce que je veux
c'est à l'eau la plus pure l'air le plus
respirable
le chiffre le plus bas en émissions de
carbone qui est une norme que je vois qu
aux bahamas en scène giorgio gelé pas
entendue a parlé et je ne crois pas
qu'ils comprennent même ce que ça veut
dire
nos gammes ascenseur nous avons les
meilleures émissions de carbone en 35
ans aux états unis grâce à ma présidence
on travaille tellement bien avec
industrie voici ce qu'on peut pas faire
regardez là chez nous à quel point la
chesnaie sage
regardez la russie regardez l'inde
c'est vraiment l'air est irrespirable
l'accord de paris les accords de paris
je nous ai sorti car il fallait dépenser
des millions de la route est traité de
façon très défavorable c'était un cdh
était pas lui rendre service cela tu es
notre entreprise
je ne veux pas sacrifier des dizaines de
millions d'emplois
les militants compagnie a causé un grand
de paris c'était tellement elle juste
lâché nous ne participe pas jusqu'en
2030 la russie retourne à énorme
précédente très faible nous fallait
qu'on l'a juste tout de suite cela
arrête détruit nos entreprises a reçus
et vous prêts on a fait un travail
remarquable sur le plan de
l'environnement
l'art le plus pur l'eau la plus bue
wable et les meilleures émissions en
carbone qu'on a vu en de nombreuses
années
l'esprit dans bayda et on n'a pas
détruit nous est de cécité dans bagdad
deux minutes sans interruption le
changement climatique le réchauffement
climatique est un danger essentiel
contre l'humanité nous avons un
impératif moral de nous y attaquer et
tous les grands scientifiques du monde
du disque on n'est pas beaucoup assez de
temps nous allons passer franchir le
point de non retour dans quelques années
il a éliminé toutes les réglementations
que l'administration obama avait adopté
pour nettoyer l'environnement pour
limiter les émissions et ça va nous met
dans une position où on va être vraiment
en danger
vous savez toutes les organisations qui
s'inquiétait des pertes d'emplois à puis
mon plan parce que ça va créer des
millions de nouveaux emplois bien payés
en vain un wc par exemple danser dans
cinquante mille postes de recharge
électrique le long de nos routes afin
que nous ayons une position dominante
dans l'industrie automobile électrique
ce que la chine fait en ce moment notre
place on va prendre des millions de
guides édifices existants afin qu'ils
réparent n'y davantage d'énergie ce qui
va nous épargner des dizaines des
centaines de milliers de baril de
pétrole
en même temps et créer des emplois
simultanément et l'idée ici c'est de
créer des millions d'emplois et nettoyer
l'environnement
donc notre santé et notre environnement
ici sont en jeu et c'est ce que nous
l'ont fait il y à des firmes sur wall
street qui ont indiqué que mon plan va
créer en fait 18 millions -6 emploie des
dizaines de millions de plus et très des
débits trilliant des billions de dollars
de plus près dans la croissance
économique
ils ont en fait
10 heures ces 1500 $ seront supprimés
des familles importe son plein que c'est
une catastrophe économique si vous
regardez ce qu'il veut faire
regardez un peu se plaint à élaborer
c'est aussi 2 3 ils connaissent
absolument rien sur le climat alexandra
au casot cortese elle pas bien mais elle
ne sait rien donc à aussi cliffs 3 les
nouvelles recrues au congrès mais là sur
lui la mère année dans l'histoire de
puissantes un même pas près d'un chiffre
comme on l'a connu car il parle des
immeubles
ils veulent détruire parce qu'ils
veulent que les grandes fenêtres soir à
tisser si vous avez aucune fenêtre ce
serait encore mieux
voilà c'est le plein le plus fou qu'on
puisse imaginer
et cela n'a pas été conçu par des gens
intelligents
non ça ne t'a pas de conçu par je ne
sais même pas comment ça peut passer
politiquement donc 100 millions de
dollars ça c'est leur vrais chiffres
il dit que c'est si mais c'est 100
billion dollar il veut détruire des
immeubles et reconstruire avec des
toutes petites fenêtres et bien d'autres
problèmes les cette chance répondre il y
en a pas beaucoup de temps à bord des
vice-présidents sais pas d'où il sort
tout ça je sais pas d'où il sort ses
chefs 100 billion de dollars
donnez moi ceci est un plan qui a été
approuvé par tous les groupes
environnementaux par les syndicats parce
qu'ils savent que l'avenir c'est un
avenir où on est capable de respirer
l'air qui nous entoure et qu'on ait des
emplois et en fait l'industrie qui
connaît la plus grande croissance la
plus rapide croissance obtenue c'est
l'industrie soit du solaires et des
éoliennes c'est lynx a grandi le plus
rapidement et ils payent des bons
salaires de 25 à 30 $ dollars on est
capable
avoir de la croissance sinon avec
proposer ensuite j'ai d'autres questions
sous sommes indépendants sur le plan
énergétique la toute première fois
on n'a pas besoin de tous ces pays qu'il
fallait investir parce qu'on avait
besoin de leur énergie
moi je comprends le vin beaucoup mieux
que toi c'est très très cher ça tue les
oiseaux c'est très intermittent et à
bien des problèmes est en fait en
allemagne et en chine
il y as si vous croisiez dans les
émissions de carbone les gaz qui monte
dans l'atmosphère pour produire ces
moules est à 20 c'est bien pire que le
gaz naturel qui est très bon mais le
solaire n'est pas rendu là c'est pas
assez puissant pour vraiment faire
tourner nos belles et grandes usines
dont on a besoin pour votre concurrent
scène par se forgeant donc c'est des
rêves wallers et les châteaux l'espagne
mais sais tu veux toujours l'économie
débarrasse toi de l'industrie pétrolière
et que dire des correcteurs c'est ma
demande
dis que je me posais foot registre à la
fracturation hydraulique je vais mettre
son site web
en fait il ment est-ce que vous
refuseriez cimentation
je ne veux pas bannir le la fracturation
hydraulique parce que on a besoin de
prendre ces industries il leur fait
faire une transition pour qu'on soit
neutre au niveau de nos émissions en 20
je veux qu'on cap sur les émissions à
partir de la fracturation hydraulique
compte capture les émissions une autre
question
attendu cette partie il était contre la
fracture est cela dit je vais montrer
cet enregistrement demain je suis contre
la fracturation
il s'est rendu en pennsylvanie après ça
ni nations unies en pennsylvanie il
valait contre parce que son parti et
contribuent encore à nos dernières
parties présentes l'ont appelé personne
de couleur on soit trouvé beaucoup plus
près dans des usines au texas et des
familles qui ont peur que les usines en
fait les rendent malade votre
administration a éliminé toutes autres
réglementations à l'encontre c'est une
pourquoi ces familles en fête vous
accorderez un nouveau mandat de la fumée
dont il est question sont des gens qui
font beaucoup de d'argent ont de très
bons emplois regarder les chiffres pour
les hispaniques les noirs les asiatiques
ces neuf fois plus qu'un de pourcentage
en trois ans que pendant huit ans sous
ces deux là pour le dire j'anime à ces
deux lascars
je n'ai pas vu les statistiques dont
vous parlez mais ils font énormément
d'argent
il se porte bien on l'a souvent cette
industrie il ya quelques mois encore
quand il ya eu la chute des prix du
pétrole on l'a
pouvez vous voudrez et dire ce que vous
voudrez mais l'arabie saoudite le
mexique et la russie ont réduit de
beaucoup leur production le sauver le
trench très très bien et maintenant à
travers bondy et chacun a donné une
dernière question pour les deux
ma réaction c'est que les gens habitent
sur un sellings et il habite juste à
l'extérieur de ces usines qui polluent
beaucoup je vivais le long d'une
raffinerie comme ça delaware c'était
terrible de la pollution qui avait dans
la voiture lorsqu'il y avait les
premières jeu lille il y avait du
pétrole sur le pare-brise peu importe qu
est ce que vous les payez
l'important c'est de les garder en
sécurité qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
d'imposer des restrictions sur les
pollutions qui sort de ces deux de ses
usines qu'il fermerait l'industrie
pétrolière s'est appuyé j'ai une
transition pour l'industrie petit romain
d'accord c'est c'est un gros et non
c'est parce qu'on est que vous voyez ça
parce que l'industrie pétrolière pour
lui venir si vive voix si c'était finir
ma déclaration parce que ce doit être
remplacé par l'énergie renouvelable mais
ça prend du temps pour faire ça moi j'ai
un retrait de leur donner des
subventions fédérales lui on ne veut pas
donner des subventions au soleil et les
olives attend-on ou aux salaires
en question mais pour la commune
dernière question à poser sur le
président va détruire l'industrie
pétrolière rappelez-vous de carla au
texas en fait s'il devenait président et
non pour répondre et ensuite on passe à
la dernière version ici
monsieur bailly l'esprit d'un bail dont
il prend tour en dehors de son contexte
les lepic la chose importante c'est
d'arriver à une un niveau d'émissions 0
est la seule façon de le faire pour 2013
une non je vais retourner dans les
accords de paris c'est là qu'ils ont
cette première question s'adresse à vous
président
imaginez que vous êtes le jour de
l'inauguration que vous diriez vous dans
le cas de votre discours aux américains
qui n'ont pas voté pour vous vous avez
juste une minute chacun commence il
bafoue le président jacques réussir
comme le pays en réaction à ce prix vis
de la chine
et maintenant on est un record de
créations d'emplois plus de 11 millions
à 70 à 20 la peste pandémie gens
recevaient des appels de gens qui
n'auraient pas osé m'appeler ils
voulaient se rassembler nous avions les
meilleures chez freud emplois chez les
noirs chez les espagnols et les femmes
les asiatiques des gens avec des
diplômes sans diplôme des diplômés de m
étaient les premiers 15 chacun avait les
marchés feraient savez vous quoi l'autre
côté voulait nous rencontrer voulais
unifier les forces le succès va nous
unir qui nous sommes sur la voie du
succès mais moi en train de réduire les
impôts et lui il veut me faire augmenter
les impôts tout le monde et méteren
nouveau règlement il va tuer notre élan
avec lui vous aurez une dépression
économique comme du jamais vu derrière
vont s'effondrer et la journée sera très
sévèrement le pays dans l'esprit 120mm
question que diriez-vous pendant votre
discours d'inauguration aux américains
qu'ils n'auront pas voté pour vous
gueule
divers je suis un président américain je
vous représente tous un chacun peut
importe si vous avez voté pour ou contre
moi et je vais m'assurer que je vous
représente
nous allons bouger nous allons choisir
la séance sur le fixe par rapport à la
fiction nous allons choisir d'aller de
l'avant parce qu'il y a des opportunités
incroyables qui nous attendent pour
améliorer les jo nous pouvons faire
croître notre économie nous pouvons
gérer ce racisme systémiques et en même
temps s'assurer que notre économie est
gérée est motivée par de l'énergie
propre qui va créer des millions de
nouveaux emplois et ça ce sont les faits
c'est ça qu'on va faire et comme je les
dis au tout début
qu'est ce qui lie à oman où vous allez
voter c'est le caractère de notre pays
la décence l'honneur traiter les gens
avec respect traiter tout le monde avec
dignité et s'assurer que tout le monde a
une chance égale et je me suis dit que
vous aurez versé
je tiens à vous remercier tous les deux
de ses fantastiques débat d'une heure et
demie très robuste merci beaucoup
monsieur le vice président biden
monsieur le président merci beaucoup à
l'université balmont nous avoir
accueillis ce soir et merci à ceux et
celles qui nous ont regardé ce soir les
élections le 3 novembre
n'oubliez pas de voter merci beaucoup et
excellente bonne nuit un travail
impeccable de la modératrice christine
roques
journal s à nbc ce soir vous avez vu un
débat fort différent pendant que vous
voyez sur la scène
oui mais la natcom qui vient rejoindre
son mari elle était elle toussait au
cours des derniers jours ont dit qu'elle
était encore malade et voilà on va se
serrer dans les bras pour ce qui est de
les familles immédiates et poursuivre
cette campagne je le disais donc un
débat fort différent civilisé avec quand
même des échanges robustes comme vient
de le dire
la journaliste tous les thèmes à peu
près importants ont été abordés dont les
changements climatiques à la toute fin
et ce qui est souvent escamotés dans les
débats de ce genre monsieur buydens
monsieur tron à leur manière ont peut
être livré le meilleur débat dans lequel
ils ont participé jusqu'ici premier tour
de table c'est intéressant parce que cet
homme je dis bravo à christine walker
effectivement bravo mais il faut dire
que ne se créent pas décidé d'arriver
avec une tout autre stratégie beaucoup
moins agressif qui a laissé parler son
adversaire donc il ne il ne voulait pas
qu'on dise à la fin qu'il était
absolument démonter il a voulu montrer
un style même le sien plus présidentiel
en passant merci à nos trois interprètes
jambes bing qui faisait une structure en
pierre
bigras qui faisait monsieur byden et
véronique theron qui faisait la
journaliste c'est un métier difficile
que de suivre en direct alors pour ceux
qui l'ont écoutée en français bravo
alors voilà j'ai 30 ans mais mes
analyses tour de table car entre monféry
gang non elizabeth va lire en fête jacob
est ce que est ce qu'ils ont à la était
à la hauteur des attentes dans les deux
cas est ce que vous y voyez un gagnant
perdant en fait jacques commence avec
vous dans chambre s'il s'est tapé le
seul faveur suite à ses performances
désastreuses ya trois semaines c'est
d'avoir mis la barre tellement base pour
ce soir en fait donc tout simplement
ne pas agir en maniaque franchement ils
en sortaient presque gagnant en
comparaison au premier débat
si on gagne à je vous dirais son idole
la soirée rap a très bien fait et en
étant beaucoup plus calme en fait il a
nettement plus écorché joe biden qu'il a
pu faire
il ya trois semaines en même temps ceci
n'est pas dans un vase clos sans une
campagne dans beaucoup plus large dans
laquelle il tire quand même largement
derrière je demeure assez sceptique
d'avoir un impact énorme suite aux
débats se sont ok mais vous dit bonne
performance du titre up de marque comme
dit il avait été tellement désastreux la
première fois que à moins d'une
performance pareille on allait dire
baïla il a pris des leçons il avait deux
vallées en effet on a pu entendre les
deux d'abord c'est déjà beaucoup
prix c'était déjà un progrès important
de pouvoir entendre les deux on a vu que
trump et et les deux d'ailleurs m hommes
particulièrement se reconnaît il a
visiblement écouté ses conseillers qui
lui a probablement dit qu'il ne fallait
pas réitérer le désastre du premier
débat et on l'a vu il y avait des
messages qu'ils étaient prêts à
construire sur lynch weiten sur cette
famille corrompue on a eu ce sentiment
il était très fluide et puis les boutons
sur lesquels ils appuyaient qui était
d'aider vraiment de qui qui était qui
construisent la campagne pour les jours
à venir
de l'autre côté bart hayden que l'on a
vu plus fatigué à la fin du débat comme
comme de tous quand on est plus fatigué
si on avait des difficultés parfois
d'élocution sait que paris donnait bègue
on voit tout de suite c'est quelque
chose qui va à choper donc c'était c'est
un match nul dans un sens dans la mesure
où les deux ont relativement bien
performé mais aucun n'a finalement
supplanté l'autre bon gagnon les dates
font toute la différence je pense que je
suis assez d'accord avec elisabeth et
raphaël pour dire que 30 pas connu un
très bon débat évidemment la comparaison
avec celui de septembre lui permettait
de connaître bien meilleur débat ce soir
s'ils se comporter autrement
mais imaginez s'il avait connu ce débat
la fin septembre c'est là où je voulais
en venir parce qu'il ya quand même des
pronostiqueurs
notamment des dix éleveurs qui ont
démontré que les débats ne font pas une
grande différence mais qui avait
démontré qu'à la fin septembre ça avait
quand même fait perdre des plumes à
monsieur tron un petit peu dans les
sondages dans les états clés de
l'élection et c'est vraiment une affaire
de momentum on ne parlait de ce débat là
ensuite il a attrapé le virus mais mais
je pense que s'il avait connu ce débat
là à la fin septembre la course serait
peut-être un petit peu plus serré en ce
moment on est à onze jours de l'élection
qu'est ce que ça peut changer
on le verra mais mais je pense qu'il ya
peut-être un petit peu tard à ce moment
si les conseillers de tron n'oseront pas
lui dire mais doivent se dire exactement
ce que vous venez de dire imagine si
l'année des comme ça la première fois
imaginé si vous n'aviez pas perdu un peu
les pédales après avoir attrapé la coved
puis partir en fou comme superman on
serait peut-être dans une autre
situation aujourd'hui mais bon on ne le
sera jamais à karine vos impressions
mais en fait je suis d'accord avec mes
collègues
moi j'ai trouvé que en fait 26 et chante
pas connu un très bon débat je pense que
joe biden a été le plus énergique le
plus le plus connecté avec la population
justement sur les thèmes qui sont à des
plus proches des gens notamment la
question des familles
la question de l'immigration par exemple
je pense que c'est là où il s'en est
mieux sorti chambre peut-être un peu
mieux fait sur les questions de sécurité
nationale pas nécessairement parce qu'il
le dit des choses vraies mais parce
qu'il a pu livrer son message le plus
marqué des points à ce moment là mais ce
sont peut-être des sujets qui sont un
peu plus loin des électeurs donc mais je
pense que en fait c'était le meilleur
débat pour tous les deux dans les
circonstances mais comme le disent mes
collègues je pense que c'est trop peu
trop tard
pour charles pour en tout cas c'est pas
du tout ce soir que ça s'est joué ou que
ça bosse se jouer dans la mesure où on
sait déjà beaucoup de gens qui ont voté
beaucoup de gens qui ont déjà leur idée
de fait alors à partir de ce moment le
jeu pas certaine que ce soit ça va mais
quand même ça donne ça redonne foi au
système politique américaine ça redonne
foi des à la possibilité d'avoir des
débats civilisé et parce que rappelez
vous on était quand même passablement
décourager la dernière fois donc il faut
trouver parce que c'est rare puis vous
l'avez tous dit si rock indé bosch
change à ce point la donne mais là au
moins la campagne va se poursuivre pour
presque quinze jours avec une lance et
plus normal en tout cas je vais aller
voir mes électeurs et je vous reviens
parce qu'on a trouvé on a bien sûr
sortie des extraits de ce débat on va
revenir plus en détails avec les thèmes
mais je veux à chaud à voir les
impressions des électeurs je commence
avec vous julie lesage bombay tout le
monde dit qu'il a fait quand même un bon
débat j'imagine que vous êtes très
contente
la dernière fois je vais pas vraiment
aimé sa personnalité dans le débat ces
postiers étaient très calmes je pense
que était patients envoyés dans son
visage qu'il y avait le goût d'en
rajouter mais on était capable de se
retenir c'est très bien alors il n'y a
pas eu de cas pas eu de changement pour
vous déjà que vous étiez vous étiez
prête à tout vous êtes rassuré un peu
quand même
je suis rassuré aussi bon il ya eu il ya
quand même eu des échanges chaud on à
votre panne en a pas parlé mais bon sur
l'immigration et à traiter les
immigrants
est faible
yu il a dit ce qu'ils reviennent à
l'audience sont pas très intelligent non
mais on va en parler tout de suite après
où vous 4 je vais donner des extraits le
qui ont marqué le débat mais je voulais
avoir à chaud aux impressions oui mais
ce point sur ce point ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce qui le disaient en
fait c'est que on sait très bien ici que
vont en fait je suis me rends donc je
sais un peu les gens qui se présentent à
ces auditions là c'est parce qu'ils
savent pas mais si je présente mon 6e
présentement ils vont pouvoir rester
beaucoup plus longtemps donc je pense
que c'était dans cette optique là qui le
dit ce qu'il a dit mais c'était
prédisant mal à bella très bien julie
lesage merci à houston au texas bonne
nuit
gérard poulet vous êtes républicain
depuis reagan avez vous dit tout à
l'heure mais vous avez voté
déjà pour joe biden est ce que ça vous
aurait peut-être fait changer d'idée le
débat de ce soir
non pas vraiment parce que je crois que
toujours les mots qui sont de sa gueule
c'est c'était masse en jeu
je crois que il va dire toute chose qui
peut mais ces sapins la vérité et et
pour moi je suis comme un meilleur prix
qui dit imagine le jour que il n'a plus
de président et j'espère je ne sais pas
mais pour moi c'est ce qui est important
c'est qu'il va accepter la décision
si c'est lui alors on a quatre otages je
pense pas que je vais déménager au
canada
ah mais si c'est pas lui je veux pas que
c'est c'est pas beau il pas leurs fusils
et cause du tout ça c'est ça m'inquiète
un peu oui
vous n'êtes pas le seul où il ya de
l'inquiétude de ce côté là on verra
merci beaucoup merci bonne nuit merci
d'avoir été là je vais voir madame blue
jays vie les attentions en arizona
alors qu'avez vous pensé du débat je
pense que c'était un bon des bras et je
suis d'accord avec tous les analystes
tantôt qui a dit le président était trop
calme
moi je suis d'accord mais le point qui
je veux parler s'est il faut mettre les
gens américain ensemble et c'était ce
n'était qu'une baleine qui a dit quelque
chose sur ça et moi j'aimais bien
l'union il a dit la réconciliation voilà
et c'était ça que bagdadi très bien
merci beaucoup
madame mon beau yayi c'est intéressant
parce qu'il a répété qu'il a fait depuis
laine que ni se compare pas les
week-ends quand même
mais depuis linken dit il je suis le
président qui en a fait le plus pour la
communauté noire de mon pays je suis là
il a dit je je je regarde je vois rien
parce qu'il fait noir dans la salle mais
je suis la personne la moins raciste de
la salle qu'avez vous pensé de sa bon
comme j'avais dit avant par rapport à
ces eti qui la polluent le plus
il a fait plus que tous les autres
présidents pour le peuple noir ça je
trouve qu'il exagère mais j'étais quand
même contente qu'il a parlé d agrément
ce que je vous avais parlé souvent à la
discrimination concernant la drogue ici
aux etats unis
il a parlé aussi de la réhabilitation et
pubs hayden
oui ils accepter que la mal fait vous
voyez ce n'était pas une question qu'ils
étaient des noirs crime et non étaient
des personnes des drogués comme son fils
qui ont été arrêtés pendant plusieurs
années
ce sera donc avec à
possession pour que les gens comprennent
bien avec ce qui se faisait arrêter avec
en possession de drogue se faisait
arrêter il a dit que c'était une erreur
d'ailleurs il avait déjà dit souvent
mais il a dit c'était une erreur de
faire ça à l'époque
oui mais c'est déjà trop tard il avait
presque 50 ans en tant que sénateur
et là il a rien fait du tout de bon pour
les noirs américains
et en plus il a fait 8 ans avec obama
obama aussi n'a rien fait pour les noirs
américains
donc la question sur l'immigration ça ne
concerne pas les noirs américains de
souche ça que c'est encore que des puits
et bien d autres pays
mais pour les noirs américains s'est
passé ça c'est pourquoi nous sommes
d'accord mais quand tu as deux byden
dans notre panel de citoyens
c'est intéressant parce que vous la
toute première fois que je vous avais
parlé vous aviez lâche et rameuses est
revenu alors deux choix mme de baden
c'est intéressant merci beaucoup on va
se reparler merci nous avons parlé à
chaud après ce débat fredreik arnall
vous êtes sur place à nashville où un
débat fort différente fort différent oui
est ce les électeurs américains qui ont
peut-être regarder le premier et qui ont
regardé le deuxième aujourd'hui il ya
une énorme différence et ça pourrait
leur laisser penser qu'effectivement
monsieur trump s'est mieux comportée
c'était plus facile d'écouter de voir
ses positions de voir un peu ses
arguments pour qu'il se fasse réélire
que ce soit des positions ou des
affirmations qui soit plus ou moins
fausses ou vraies c'est pas important ce
que tu as pensé le message qu'il a
projeté et là dessus vous aviez monsieur
monsieur byron qui était un peu égal à
lui même par rapport à la première
partie de la campagne le premier débat
sauf que vers la fin on sentait qui il
manquait un peu moins de mordant en fait
bon monsieur trump la pique est pas mal
sur les fameuses huit années qui a passé
à la maison blanche aux côtés de barack
obama
vous n'avez pas fait ceci vous parlez
beaucoup mais vous n'avez pas fait
grand-chose hélas les démocrates aurait
peut-être aimé que monsieur bailon
rentrer un peu plus là dedans et se
défendre alors on verra
toute façon on le sait il ya peut-être
quoi 4 % des américains qui n'ont pas
encore vraiment fait leurs idées mais si
on regarde les chiffres de participation
jusqu'ici 47 millions et demi déjà qui
se sont prononcés est-ce que ça va
vraiment être un game challenger est ce
que ça va changer de la langue
complètement ce serait surprenant il
reste un peu plus de 11 jours maintenant
mais c'est un débat qui était beaucoup
plus intéressant pour savoir un peu
quelles étaient les positions et la
façon dont les gens se défendent et dans
le fond avait tout à fait c'est un bon
débat c'est un bon débat un débat ça
change pas tout mais c'est un un débat
qu'on suivait bien les sujets importants
ont été abordés d'ailleurs je vous je
vous jure on auprès d'ex trail à vous
montrer mon avis monsieur convoi avec
nos analyses revenir mais les deux
frédéric ont défendu leur intégrité
oui parce que dans le fond c'est souvent
revenu sur sur la table de ce fameux
débat et vous savez les américaines ont
ils vont choisir en fonction de leurs
préférences politiques mais aussi en
fonction des programmes des plateformes
qui ont été mises de l'avant par les
deux il reste quand même qu'ils votent
pour un homme pour une personnalité pour
une façon de gérer et de s'approprier
des situations et c'est de changer les
choses et là dessus mais les deux se
sont vraiment présenté comme ceux qui
allaient vraiment la respecter plus la
vérité l'effet changé un peu la décence
l'autre allez dire mais moi écouter
c'est ma façon de faire c'est ma façon
de gérer donc il ya tout le côté
intégrité le côté personnalités voici
deux extraits boutabout justement des
deux hommes
le clip stock de parrot c'est pas de
tout ce que tu vas faire ceci cela les
têtes et l'oeil a pas encore si
longtemps et vous n'avez rien vu si les
gars dau écoute moi je me suis présenté
tout cela vous savez qui il est vous
connaissez
sa personnalité est la mienne vous savez
que moi j'ai une personnalité ne parlait
pas de cette innocence
non on te qualifies des politiciens
quand cinq anciens dirigeants du
seigneur qui venait des deux partis
d'ailleurs qui disent que lui ce qu'il
raconte c'est de la foutaise intéressant
frédéric parce qu'on voit quand même que
ton du conte on pourra entendre les deux
jambes ne veut pas dire que c'était
c'était plate là il ya eu de chahut de
bons échanges la wii est exactement et
je pense que ça aidera peut-être les
dernières personnes qui n'ont pas encore
fait leur choix je vous parle beaucoup
de bruit parce que justement on voit le
fameux cortège présidentiel qui quitte
ici juste devant nos yeux
donc voilà monsieur choï qui quittent
l'université bellmunt ici pour repartir
en campagne parce que c'est ça qui fait
c'est ça qu'ils aiment faire et donc il
va continuer de colporter ces positions
et s'ils s'attaquent aussi face à
monsieur by day by day on va voir ce
qu'il va faire dans les prochains jours
on sait que jusqu'ici sni campagne c'est
assez mollo assez relax on veut pas trop
sortir pas trop faire de vagues
deux styles qui ont vraiment été
représentée ce soir dans la façon dont
ils ont argumenté l'un l'attaquent
l'autre plus à la défensive et au bout
du conte d'alice sont pas mal équilibré
on va dire ce soir parce que la formule
a permis ce genre d' échanges
intéressants pour les électeurs elle a
été bonne madame walker a été bonne elle
a été elle a piqué les deux clans piquet
et piquet l'autre ensuite le c'était pas
mal réparti également que monsieur trump
il avait discrédité
avant même le débat dont c'est bien elle
est du côté des démocrates mais alors en
tout cas mon humble avis bien fait son
travail alors bravo
ça va vite ces débats là merci frédéric
lui alors vous allez continuer à porter
à couvrir ça pour nous comme vous le
dites monsieur chrome va continuer les
rallyes sur les tarmacs peu partout et
il va être beaucoup en floride
ils voient beaucoup et en pennsylvanie
il va aller dans le mes doit s il va
constamment se rendre dans les états
clés oui parce qu'il sait que c'est là
qui peut gagner dans le fond c'est là
qu'il faut absolument qu'il gagne il ne
faut pas que son électorat sa base
s'effrite six f-16 frites un petit peu
ce soit chez les évangéliques les
latinos les personnes âgées ou les
femmes de banlieue
ça va être difficile de remporter ce
fameux est à quai alors il faut qu'il
martèle le même message et il va le
faire il va faire le tout pour le tout
onze jours c'est pas beaucoup pour
renverser la tendance mais on sent déjà
que ça ça sera frais permis un petit peu
au niveau des écarts mais il reste que
monsieur by john a quand même une bonne
avance pour l'instant alors c'est à
suivre
c'est une campagne malgré tout assez
enlevante il faut le dire ben oui tout à
fait quand même merci beaucoup
frédéric merci pour tout ça alors car il
ne faudrait qu'ils habitent raphaël je
vous propose un premier extrait sur la
coved a été d'entrée de jeu le premier
sujet du débat est là monsieur ne chante
pas étonné en dix ans d'ici quelques
semaines un vaccin en excédent
nous avons un vaccin qui est prêt qui va
être annoncé d'ici quelques semaines et
il sera livré nous avons l'opération
robes speed qui est sous la direction
d'hélène emparé d'un vaccin qui seraient
proposés dans quelques semaines est ce
une garantie ce n'est pas une garantie
non si la fin de l'année punk 46 mais il
ya deux entreprises c'est une question
de semaines
et ce sera distribué très rapidement
quelles mesures prendre et vous pour
instaurer la confiance dans un vaccin
je me suis rappelé la scion que le
processus est absolument transparent
avec les scientifiques examineront un
processus et en passant ça c'est le même
gars qui vous a dit que seul effet
terminé
à pâques ne vous inquiétez pas d'ici
l'été ce sera terminé
écoutez on se dirige vers un univers
sombre
il n'a pas de plan clair et il n'y a pas
de possibilité que la majorité des
américains auront un vaccin avant la mi
mots t-il alors autour de tables nappées
de là dessus il n'y a pas eu de grande
surprise année on a été on a été étonné
d'ici quelques semaines on s'est dit est
ce que il sait des choses que l'on ne
sait pas monsieur jobs
vous allez me dire mais comme président
ce serait normal mais comment il s'est
lui-même rétracter je commence avec vous
car il est en fait ça fait longtemps
qu'il sait qu'il promet un vaccin pour
la fin de l'année on parlait de la
surprise d'autres tops éventuellement
maintenant tabac chef memet jaune ça
fait un bout de temps qu'ils parlent de
ça ils étaient un petit peu plus et le
plus en fait peut-être calmer le jeu en
dit un peu plus tard baisse pas une
garantie mais en tout cas on est proche
de ça donc je pense que c'est cette idée
de 2,2 de faire croire aux gens que ça
va se produire et peut-être de les
amener à voter pour lui mais encore une
fois je pense que c'est une façon aussi
pour lui de montrer qu'il est dans
l'action qu'il est en train de prendre
des décisions
elisabeth c'est je trouve que ça
correspond tout à fait à la politisation
de la politique sanitaire depuis depuis
le départ encore une fois l'approbation
du rem des civils par la f10 est
aujourd'hui correspond exactement à ça
c'est un médicament dont l'efficacité
est contestée par le web s est malgré
tout la f10 et vianne de l'approuver
donc il fera ce qu'il faut pour essayer
de donner le sentiment que il maîtrise
la
la résolution de la crise en quelque
sorte y compris dire affirmé cette chose
alors que fao çi lui-même dit que
l'horizon est plus dans un an
quant à déployer les militaires pour
administrer le vaccin c'est encore une
autre paire de manches
il y avait vraiment beaucoup d'éléments
dans une seule phrase messieurs je veux
vous faire entendre un autre extrait
avant de faire parler sur la coved ces
cas les deux visions là se sont
affrontés et bien défini les deux
visions monsieur john dill voulait
fermer l'économie moi je veux ouvrir les
écoles d'ouvrir new york j'aime ma ville
je reconnais plus ma ville je baille
donne dit on peut on peut ouvrir mais
faut être prudent lanvin deux visions on
n'écoute pas ce qu'on peut ainsi on peut
pas garder ce pays fermé c'est un pays
énorme avec une économie gigantesque les
gens perdent leur emploi ils se su il ya
des polices qui explose la violence et
il veut fermer le pays
si une seule personne dans notre bureau
quasi massive dit de fermer yves à
l'écrit capable de marcher et mâcher de
la gomme en même temps il faudrait être
capable d'ouvrir de manière sécuritaire
et ça prend des ressources pour réouvrir
notre économie et c'est pas de manière
inconséquent de dire qu'on va le faire
de manière sécuritaire
en passant ce et vous les professeurs y
en a pas beaucoup qui vont mourir ne
vous inquiétez pas les données moins de
chance
alors c'est intéressant parce qu'on
adore les deux visions qui
s'affrontaient à faire après juste pour
rebondir sur ce que rien n'arrête dix
ans a dit tantôt c'est important de le
souligner dans notre chambre ça fait
depuis le printemps dernier qui promet
qu'un vaccin qui s'en vient d'ici la fin
de l'année il y a même évoqué que ça
arrive d'ici l'élection l'on est rendu à
un jour d'élection donc ça je pense que
c'est la première chose qui doit est dit
la deuxième c'est que écouté patrice
vous disiez je suis d'accord largement
avec votre la modératrice enfin bon
travail ce soir si une petite exception
à ça et qui m'a profondément agacé c'est
qu'on a pas au sport la question
suivante aux deux candidats la question
suivante donc est associée
s'il n'y a pas de vaccin qui s'en vient
dans le court le moyen bataille même le
long terme
quel est votre plan précis pour gérer la
situation
on n'a jamais vraiment eu de questions
en ce sens et de réponses dans ce sens
et non plus et je me permets d'ajouter
ceci également que j'avais voulu
mentionner lors du premier tour de table
après la fin du débat pour vous
rattraper look et non mais c'est
fondamental patrice parce que tout le
monde moi le premier avons dit que cette
course là à l'est pas nécessairement
changer du tout au tout alors il n'y a
pas seulement une élection
présidentielle le 3 novembre
il ya des élections au congrès et la
bataille pour le sénat s'annonce
extrêmement chaude et donc si dans leur
chambre et capable de redresser
éventuellement sa possible marge de
défaite par deux ou trois points et les
républiques et parfois être sauvé des
sièges en quarts maintenant en iowa qui
vont faire la différence entre une
majorité républicaine majorité démocrate
au sénat et sa patrie ce pour les quatre
prochaines années une éventuelle
possible de présidence barrés dance est
absolument fondamentale dont il faut pas
se leurrer c'est pas comme si je me suis
trompé je pouvais avoir aucun impact sur
la trajectoire politique non seulement
de la fin de la campagne mais
possiblement des prochaines années
également le parti peaufine il ya plein
de ce n'est pas que la présidentielle
sauf au sol rappelaient effectivement
frédéric sur le lac au vide
est ce que quelqu'un d'après vous ont
marqué des points ouvrant chacun parlait
assez à ceux qui croient comme lui c'est
un enjeu dont monsieur 30 veut qu'on
parle le moins possible en pour des
cheveux pour des raisons qu'on a évoqué
souvent à l'émission ici bon il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont très
mécontents de son bilan sur cette
question là mais je dirais qu'à la
différence du dernier débat de septembre
où trempent était sur la défensive ne
répondaient pas vraiment aux questions
passer à l attaque tout de suite empêché
baden de terminer ses phrases
mais l'octroi pour moi a présenté sa
vision il c'est assumé il a dit ben on a
des visions très différentes
moi je pense qu'on ne doit pas en faire
trop pour causé plus de tort que le
virus est un peu son idée est tout à
leur appel d'air on ne sait pas ce qu'il
ferait s'il n'y a pas de vaccin mais
tremplin un petit peu dit indirectement
en disant il faut apprendre à vivre avec
le virus va apprendre à vivre avec le
virus évidemment c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à faire pour les gens qui sont
en situation très précaire aux états
unis mais je pense qu'il peut marquer
des points auprès de certains indécis
parce qu'on est toujours un petit peu
allergique aux états unis à des
interventions de l'état un petit peu
trop loin
2 dans la vie des gens et baden a
clairement dit que il n'hésiterait pas
dire qu'il faut porter un masque de
façon un petit peu plus systématique aux
états unis donc je pense que 30
peut-être convaincu certains indécis ou
du moins c'est une stratégie plus
efficace ce soir que de paraître
toujours sur la défensive sur cette
question là comme il l'a fait au premier
débat 70 parce qu'il n'est pas le seul à
penser ça alors effectivement et c'est
pour ça que je trouve ça intéressant cet
extrait là parce que les deux visions
ont eu le loisir de s'exprimer que les
gens décideront on verra on verra qui
gagne qu'il importe
bon on te le fils de monsieur bart
hayden s'est il bien défendu est ce que
monsieur tschopp avait de bons arguments
ce qu'on a appris quelque chose je pense
sûrement voir entendre c'est cet extrait
s'est quant à lui accru par rapport à
l'ukraine
on a examiné toute cette question est
oui parce qu'il était sur le conseil
d'administration de brousse un chèque
personnes lorsque lors du processus de
destitution qui a témoigné a dit que moi
j'avais fait mon travail de manière et
pas comme mon fils n'a pas fait d'argent
concernant cette chose de quoi qui parle
de la chine son fils étaient au chômage
pendant longtemps
tristement il n'était plus militaire dit
qu'il est devenu vice-président
bruissement pas la meilleure réputation
mode
j'entends dire qu'il lyon 2 nice 83
mille ans de cela par mois
alors votre fils a dit monsieur tron ne
faisait pas d'argent il n'était plus
dans les forces militaires grâce à votre
nom sous-entend t-il puis il a été
engagé dans cette firme pétrolière
ukrainienne qu'il faisait savent plus de
cent mille dollars par mois est-ce que
d'abord on n'a rien appris de nouveau
mais est-ce que c'était utile pour me
surprend parce qu'il a semé un doute
d'après-vous karim c'était l'objectif en
tout cas je pense que maiden
finalement a tenté de répondre le plus
clairement possible à ces accusations la
évidemment effectivement il n'ya pas de
dépôt d'accusations formelles c'est une
espèce de faux scandale en réalité mais
de le balayer sous le tapis ça n'a pas
servi beaucoup abandonnent dans les
dernières semaines
1 est ce qu est ce que le doute est semé
il était probablement déjà auprès de la
base d'autres champs est-ce que ça va
avoir convaincu d'autres personnes mais
ça s'est toujours pas clair non plus
frédéric mais il a clairement dit
monsieur bart hayden écoutez vous avez
ici de me prendre et ça fait longtemps
que vous essayez de me prendre sur cette
question là notamment cnn procédure de
destitution sur la sphère ukrainienne au
congrès s cabaret de l'indicé qui a des
républicains en fait qui ont étudié la
question et qui disent qu ariel donc ça
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant ou du moins
c'était c'était quand même une réponse
assez efficace de la part de monsieur
bart hayden de lier les républicains à
ça et on se demande depuis le début si
bart hayden ne va pas parler des enfants
de monsieur trompe aussi parce qu'il
faut le dire
jared kushner le gendre de monsieur
trappe et responsable la diplomation au
moyen orient
ivanka trump à un poste au sein de la
maison blanche
mais mme hayden ne le fait pas parce que
ça contredirait son image de politicien
ou deux candidats qui mise sur la
décence qui ne fait pas trop dans la
basse politique ça tombe bien il n'y
avait pas tomber dans le piège ce soir
et je pense qu'on lui avait dit de ne
pas tomber dans le piège
et ça tombe bien parce que l'autre
extrême et justement va écouter ce que
je voudrais parole aux eaux remarquez ça
ils usent de choses d'autres extraits il
paraît de la chaîne glenn et aux virées
sur les les familles mais il répond à ce
que vous direz tant d un mois je veux
pas mr d'attac familial on écoute c'est
pas pour votre famille ou de la mienne
ses propos de votre famille et si votre
famille qui souffrent en ce moment
si vous êtes une famille de la classe
moyenne vous êtes en difficulté en ce
moment vous êtes assis et la table ce
matin et là on peut pas s'acheter des
pneus il va falloir attendre un autre
mois est ce qu'on va être capable de
payer notre hypothèque ce mois ci qu'est
ce que vous allez dire à votre enfant
qui peut pas retourner au collège
communautaire
vous savez moi j'ai grandi dans une
famille de classe moyenne rescrit tonnes
et ces familles là ont des problèmes en
ce moment et c'est la dernière chose
qu'il veut aborder la question portait
sur la chine et là on a vu manh et
c'était un peu bizarre
c'est pourquoi il sort cette ligue là
mais je voulais vous la faire entendre
parce que justement préféré que j'avais
parlé du fait qu'il ne veut pas lui
attaqué la famille de troy alors ceci
dit pour le reste c'est pas un peu
bizarre et isabelle quand j'ai perçu ce
moment mais moi j'ai trouvé que le mot
important qui revenue deux fois pendant
le débat c'est celui de la table de
cuisine et au fond c'est ce que c'est ce
que cherchait c'était important s'est il
voulait et vous allez remarquer qu'il
avait adopté la même stratégie buy donne
que celle qui a marqué marchés au
premier débat
à un moment donné ils se tournent ils
parlent aux habits noirs il parle à nos
familles qui ont du mal à faire face
dans la crise économique et il manque
quelqu'un à la table de cuisine où vous
et on vous voyez les gens assis autour
de la table de cuisine se dire comment
est ce qu'on va annoncer à notre fille
qu'elle ne pourra pas retourner qu'on
n'aura pas les moyens de lui payer le
collège de vous cette année donc c'était
un message efficace mais effectivement
ils ont tous les deux dit graisser à
plusieurs moments le tea party est
arrivé à un moment donné dans un autre
sujet donc on a vu un peu cette tendance
à la digression mais au fond les normes
du débat avait été faite de telle
manière qu en voyait qu'il se retenait
graduellement les uns et les autres il y
avait beaucoup de choses à dire sur la
chine
ça a été effleurée je pense qu'ils
avaient déçu des des sujets beaucoup
plus cruciaux a abordé notamment le
leadership américain dans
l'asie-pacifique le positionnement de la
chine aussi dans les espaces publics et
ses voisins qui ont été là aussi quand
même relativement rapidement balayée
sous le tapis sur la politique
extérieure sur les relations avec la
chaîne avec la corée
est-ce que ce qu'on est plus avancée
est-ce que selon vous est un des deux
heures marquer des points car et mais en
fait je pense que les 200 sont venus à
leur message je pense que tout va et
d'une a eu un peu plus de difficultés
avec la chine parce que c'est pas
certain que sa politique sera aussi
différent que ce uniquement l'égard des
pratiques commerciales de la chine
alors à partir de ce moment là il était
un peu coincé sur ce sujet là donc il
répétait je le ferai je ferai jouer la
chine je lui ferai jouer les règles
internes à je m'assurer qu'elles
respectent les règles et pas grand chose
de plus à dire que ça l'appel ou la
comparaison avec hitler quand on parle
de la corée du nord
bon faut toujours faire un peu attention
avec ces cons mais raison là mais c'est
une image forte que peut-être remarqué
les gens mais je peux certainement faire
que ça change grand chose et encore une
fois si les débats ont peu d'importance
les questions de politique étrangère
dans les débords non encore moins
généralement alors je dirais que c'est
peut-être match nul à cet égard le jeu
c'est intéressant parce qu'il est rare
qu'on parle de prolifération et de
contrôle des armements et là pour une
fois c'est sur le tapis ça probablement
pas été là depuis une trentaine d'années
nostre c'était vraiment intéressant
parle de quelque chose qui est vraiment
crucial sur le plan de la sécurité
internationale et que ce soit ce point
là qui étaient abordées en priorité il
ya vraiment une course aux armements
alors qu'on se parle et qui pourrait
avoir un impact à un moment donné sur la
sécurité internationale si le système
international reprend pas du mieux mais
si là je veux pas brûler d'étapes mais
restons une seconde sur la chine sibide
l'emportait est ce que pour le canada ça
faciliterait les choses dans son rapport
avec la chine est-ce que buydens ne
serait non pas plus mou mais plus
conciliant et de sorte que nos deux
michael pourrait peut-être espérer voir
la lumière du jour en jour
frédéric les méthodes serait différente
parce que évidemment bailon recours est
davantage aux canaux diplomatiques
traditionnel alors que trump tweet à
propos de la chine c'est un peu plus
imprévisible mais je suis d'accord avec
karen prémont avec karine j'ai dit son
nom de famille que je fais je sais pas
pourquoi elle est là sur une
leur dada les déchets si je fais les
deux maladies c'est que bon à ce que
j'allais dire c'est que si vous lisez
l'article que jordan a fait paraître
dans la revue
oui fait état de sa vision de la
politique étrangère ce qui dit sur la
chaîne ressemble quand même pas mal à ce
que les républicains disent depuis
longtemps et commence à y avoir un
consensus entre les deux parties à cette
idée qu'on doit adopter une politique
plus dure à l'égard de la chaîne parce
qu'on constate bien qu'un déclin des
etats-unis dans le monde que la chine
prend du galon et qu'on perd le contrôle
de cette de cette relation-là de cette
situation là mais évidemment bail de ne
pouvait pas trop le dire parce que ça
s'arrête un aveu finalement que trump a
quand même fait un certain nombre de
choses intéressantes du point de vue des
démocrates sur cette question ce qui
m'amène à souligner le rapidement je
veux parler de la santé après que sibide
l'emportent ya pas de révolution dans la
politique étrangère américaine les m&a
qu'elle ne redevienne pas le gendarme
on ne renvoie pas déjà en afghanistan
raphaël
il n'y a pas de changement si drastiques
m c'est vrai que sur bien des points
indirectement joe biden s'est un petit
peu rallye derrière le président attend
une réponse qui a été donnée non pas ce
soir il ya deux semaines lors du débat
présidentiel qui est quand même très
importantes sur les relations
sino-américaines et c'est par rapport à
cette énorme dispute commerciale fait
qu'on semble avoir oublié avec la
pandémie des derniers mois mais la
réalité ce qu'il ya c'est fait
maintenant à peu près un an qu'on a des
deux plus grandes économies de la
planète qui se livrent une guerre
tarifaire et la très mauvaise
présidentielle comme la russe et la
colistière de monsieur bart hayden a dit
a indiqué assez clairement que ciel et
monsieur bart hayden sont conduits au
pouvoir ils vont abolir les tarifs
douaniers américains sur les
exportations chinoises aux états unis ce
n'est quand même pas rien et ça serait
un point de départ assez dramatique
merci avec la proche d'administration
actuel donc je pense que c'est quand
même pas à sous-estimer surtout quand on
considère non seulement les impacts sur
les deux économies en question et il
demande l impact indirect sur tout et
sur l'économie de la planète qui en
dépendent
incluant celle du canada bon allez même
outil mais un peu le même objectif c'est
là où je voulais être un moyen très bien
santé c'est la préoccupation vaut quand
même pas l'oublier de première quand on
fait une liste de démotivation pour
aller voter aux états unis un peu
partout mais en tout cas c'est très
important je vous fait entendre un
extrait donc de bayonne et de tram ou
les deux ont tenté de défendre leur
vision encore une fois différent le
président et moi c'est que je ne pense
pas que les soins de santé soit un
privilège c'est un droit
tout le monde devrait avoir droit à des
soins santé qu'il petit peu se payer
comme il y en a qui se demande qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire si jamais il tombe
malade parce qu'ils ont perdu
l'assurance maladie qui venaient avec
leur emploi il nous faut être capable de
livres je sais rien il veut une médecine
socialisée
c'est pas que lui le veut écouter c'est
sa vice présidente elle est plus à
gauche que billy 102 alors c'est
l'éternel débat est ce que tu chantes
pas donner des détails sur par quoi il
remplacerait ce que quelqu'un parce que
tout à l'heure
on july lesage haute examinait déjà de
voir des détails sur ce qu'il ferait lui
est ce qu'on est plus avancée à karine
non on doit le déçu parce que l'on n'a
pas eu de détails de chambre ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il dit je vais vous
présenter mon plan sur la santé ne
perdez pas patience et ça fait quatre
ans qu'ils me disent oh maintenant et on
l'a toujours pas ce plan là ça a permis
à dubaï d'une part est d'expliquer un
peu mieux qu'il l'avait fait au premier
départ
quelles seraient les prochaines étapes
pour lui concernant les soins de santé
mais c'est clair que les républicains au
programme chose à se mettre sous la dent
pour pour pour faire leur campagne et je
parle certains systèmes en des
dessinateurs et des représentants parce
qu'on a rien à présenter aux américains
pour remplacer obama club tour de table
rapide sur cette question de la santé
frédéric non je suis assez d'accord il
n'y a pas eu de détails et ce qui est
compliqué pour monsieur tron et les
républicains l'ont bien réalisé c'est
qu'obama caire devient plus populaire au
fur et à mesure que le temps passe et
c'est compliqué de garantir l'adoption
d'une réforme de santé au congrès obama
pourrait vous en parler longtemps et
c'est un peu la difficulté de 30 je
trouve ce soir ils essaient de de faire
de ramener l'attention sur le bilan
d'obama et de baden
mais obama est une figure populaire aux
états unis ce n'est pas tout le monde
qu'il l'est mais il ya des gens qui
réalisent que finalement ces huit années
là n'était peut-être pas aussi pire
qu'on le dit quand on a voté contre les
démocrates en 2010 et en 2014 aux
élections de mi mandat notamment sur
cette question-là de la santé bon et
lisa bête dans le sileo les états unis
sont ceux dont l'espérance de vie est la
plus faible c'est aussi le pays où la
mortalité des femmes en couche augmente
alors qu'elles diminuent partout par
ailleurs on a vu des gens devoir
rationner leurs insulines parce que
contrairement à ce que dit simple prix
de l'insuline a augmenté pendant son
mandat
donc tous ces éléments là font que les
gens vont être favorable aux affordable
care act alors on entend parfois des
gens dire que non ils ne volent pas de
bakker mais quand on leur dit oui mais
ce système du affaires de bacharach
parise a donc ça on est pour
donc il ya comme une espèce de
de schizophrénie parfois cih certains
certains électeurs mais c'est certain
que cet élément là le fait de pouvoir
avoir accès à un soin de santé qui est
effectivement à un droit et non pas un
privilège c'est quelque chose qui parle
aux américains particulièrement en temps
de pandémie
les martys culièrement au moment où
quand on comptera gnco vide
on pourrait imaginer que ceux ci
deviennent une condition préexistante
le mieux est l'ennemi du bien et les
gens du camp même dans le fond avec ce
qu'on a peut-être pas si mal raphaël
mais frédéric évoqué barack obama barack
obama était en rallye si on peut
l'appeler ainsi électorale pour dubaï
dernière en pennsylvanie est ce qu'ils
disent c'est que ça faisait dix ans que
les républicains promettait de remplacer
obamacare avec quelque chose et ce
quelque chose là bon le jamais vu et on
fait donc ce problème là deux heures
date de bien avant l'arrivée dans notre
champ par la présidence et même sur la
scène politique américaine et de deux on
l'a vu au tout début de la présidence
trappe alors que là la première promesse
la promesse principale en matière de
politique intérieure du nouveau
président james était de remplacer
obamacare est une des raisons
fondamentales pour lesquelles on a
échoué au congrès qui était contrôlée
dans les deux sens par les républicains
c'est qu'on ne s'entendaient pas sur un
plan clair de remplacement et donc ça ça
continue à être un espèce de boule est à
la cheville du parti républicain et
c'est pas pour rien que le président
depuis des semaines et des mois promet
un plan détaillé d'ici deux semaines et
que ça ne vient jamais le bon le moment
que j'ai trouvé le plus intéressant le
plus animé le jeu lui qui est venu
peut-être enfin me chercher le plus
c'est quand ils ont parlé de ces
réfugiés des enfants qui ont été séparés
des parents on a beaucoup parlé de ces
histoires je vous propose un petit
extrait on va parler après c'est
peut-être le moment en tout cas
by dun à paris le plus le plus sûr de ce
qu'il disait
par rapport aux valeurs qu'il veut
défendre on écoute pour revenir les
enfants c'est vraiment
mais beaucoup de ces enfants traversant
leurs parrains des coyotes des passeurs
des gains ces 500 enfants et plus sont
venus ici avec leurs enfants ils les ont
séparés à la frontière en tant que des
sites que cette stat yves c'est pas des
caillols les coyotes qui les emmenait
ils ont été amenés par leurs parents ils
ont été séparés de leurs parents